there's no time o clock hey everybody
out there it's episode 185 I can't
believe that [ __ ] hundred eighty-five
we're almost like - what you think I'm
lying
yeah um we're almost at like 200 200
weeks we're gonna have to do we've been
talking about this but maybe at the
200th episode we might have to do a live
stream yeah but I that needs to do some
planning like I said cuz I want to have
it like at them at the best time for
everybody like to watch it yeah we've
got to get onto that live stream game
yeah some of the other channels that I'm
friends with like weapons and stuff
British channel that guy will sit there
to talk about Corona and they just just
keep sending in money's actually change
it change it change it and I actually
really like every now and then like I
like I said we like Dan Bell's channel
he does devils and he does another dirty
room and sometimes on Saturday nights he
will do a live stream like from a gross
ass hotel room he puts he edits them and
puts them up later on but it's like the
live stream was there funny because you
get to just see him sitting around
smoking cigarettes yeah like that like
talking about disgusting the [ __ ]
room is yeah and it's like it's it's
super fun so we should probably do that
I mean the thing is I don't think that
it probably wouldn't be that much
different because I record the shows
live like I don't take much out a live
stream no cannot replace a standard show
yeah it has to be a in addition to
that's what I mean it would be like a
special yeah thing like right around the
200th episode is popular we can continue
or maybe when we get to 10,000
subscribers or one of those like when we
do a milestone usually usually what the
deal is from what I've been seeing
you've got to have a lot of subscribers
for a live stream to be successful yeah
that's what I'm thinking but if you
start live streaming streaming do you
get more subscribe
live screaming live if you start by
steaming doesn't actually get you more
subscribers I don't know it's a catch to
enlighten dia it's like a catch-22
except like in a good way but yeah so
you know I don't know we'll see how it
goes it's like I said I definitely want
to do like playing like what time we're
gonna do it stuff like that but either
around the 200th episode or when we get
10,000 subscribers I will think about
probably doing one problem with a live
stream is that we have to have
everything queued up too we have things
to talk about
yeah you know everything to talk about
then the live streams [ __ ] dead
although you never seem to have that
problem if we're gonna do a live stream
do a live stream we got to do it on some
kind of current event that everybody
else is talking about so we can throw
our - yeah I mean if they've got like
something kinda current or and relevant
to that time frame yeah like if it was
some kind of big crunch like for example
let's say something was going on with
like the golden sea killer or something
like that and like I said if we went off
on tangents I mean we do that on the
show anyway just as long as we had some
kind of thing we talked about into like
kick start right say [ __ ] right now what
would be relevant would be Corona right
yeah we could talk about Corona or
something else is happening in the news
that you know I don't know if you guys
agree with me go ahead and say so in the
in the comments section yes I probably
definitely do one this year it's just I
have to decide like the logistics of it
and when we're gonna do it and what time
we're gonna do it and whatever sometimes
about it sometimes thinking about it too
much is more complicated than just
[ __ ] do well wait you know how much I
have to think about everything okay well
I have to overthink everything yeah
because I have to you know I'm kind of
the one that has to like determine you
know when it's gonna go up and what cuz
I have to do all the technical [ __ ] cuz
Liam from weapons and stuff will just
turn his damn camera on and just start
time okay what questions do you have for
the carotids yeah he does a daily corona
update yeah and and answers all kinds of
questions about masks what's a good
protective mask and you know where a
master washing he's dead
you know he's dead get all your get all
your shots he's the Gary Numan of
[ __ ] face masks alright thank you
he's got that Asperger's you know where
he knows everything about NBC gear
you know that's his thing but that's
good that's good yeah just Corona came
out of the blue and he's now he's now
the NBC specialist of the internet yeah
they're hitting him and asked him to
every question that's awesome that it's
very yeah every man I mean it's not
always in time it's not awesome where
his greatness lies and you know where
his greatness Rises there's a there's a
place in time for every skill set I
believe that's true
oh yes yes any man who's ever done any
time the army understands that there's a
place in time for every skill set
it's like as lame as some of the talents
that I have are I feel like no you go
I'm glad that I live in this time period
when like his [ __ ] is her skill set
is she's a great writer and she's a
[ __ ] grammar nazi and a spelling Nazi
she knows she knows how to spell
everything and she knows every every
[ __ ] like Senate structure and how to
form paragraphs right and you know she's
I love that kind of [ __ ] she's into that
I know it's dorky but it's like yeah
also another thing that actually has
really served me well is that I'm real
good at figuring out technical [ __ ] mmm
even if I don't I don't care about it
and it like I resent having to do it she
worries too much about but you know what
I mean like if somebody said hey
designed me a website I'm like I don't
want to do that but like when I go and
like actually look and I'm like oh okay
and I did it yeah you know I mean even
though I have learned how to do it okay
are there any shoutouts there are a lot
the last show that we did um we actually
recorded it earlier like much earlier
than we normally would yes we had some
like issues were like with what not so
there were a lot of like patrons and
stuff that I didn't get to call out on
the last show like on the John Wayne
Gacy one just because we recorded it
like way before anybody came on so we
have a lot of like people to shout out
so we have several new patrons and
please please forgive me if I'm
butchering your names but we have one
named Sierra and I hope I'm pronouncing
that right all right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah her and her boyfriend yeah how you
doing sir
um one named Melissa yeah and one named
how please tell me cuz you I know you've
been talking to this person like online
with the exes and it with the ex how do
you find out that I don't know you speak
Portuguese how do you not know that's
well I mean it's Spanish the employee
yeah it's not the same because it's
Spanish that would be something like a Z
that's what I well that's what I would
have assumed in Portuguese that's not a
Z that's a SH or it's an SH Casas C I
would have thought that it was like Z so
I would have said Xanadu that sounds
like what I was there an accident or
cross there's that there above the first
day Sanada see that's kind of what I was
thinking Ali's another I thought I
haven't taken Spanish since the fourth
grade I took French and Portuguese I
grew up with Portuguese and as a
teenager living in Brazil it's it's
instinctive to me now really back when I
was back when I was around all those
damn brazilian girls as a teenager I
used to dream in Portuguese yeah yeah
you're so it's funny because even though
you don't use it on a daily basis like I
hear you sometimes like talking to
people online cuz you for a time you
were like talking to much people and you
know like about motorcycles and stuff
yeah and I would hear you talking and
you would just like go right into
Portuguese yeah it was nothing
yeah you can't think about it if you
think about it then you'll [ __ ] yeah
well because you had a tutor yeah you
were living well I all my friends were
and that - you were kind of it my
friends were kind of bilingual yeah I
started but they got sick of translating
everything for me so there was like [ __ ]
you you know you we're not talking to
you anyway they say and I'll say you had
to figure actually I understood I'm
[ __ ] up I understood what they were
saying yeah but I couldn't speak it
understanding it and speaking at a lot
of different things right so I'd have
them translate for me they they got sick
of that [ __ ] after every three or four
month I mean I had the same thing I took
French for several years and I
understood about 70% of what people were
saying to me in French but I could
probably only speak like 20 or 30 what
happened one night what happened one
night is it oui
blitzed I was about 16 or 17 [ __ ]
handle on Casa Kasasa and other things
like Fogo Paulista police which is kind
of like the Brazilian version of
Southern Comfort or Drambuie or
something anyway I got loaded and all
sudden just started speaking for it to
use I got [ __ ] pissed because I
wanted to say something to somebody and
they wouldn't translate so I just got
pissed and just stand there just
serviced and they're like see you could
speak it oh yeah they started laughs you
big [ __ ] liar like you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] gringo you kids they
got rid of your inhibit yeah right the
inhibition swing that's why yes the
inhibitions went away I was I didn't
care if I made any mistakes so yeah it
started [ __ ] fly on our chest and
then when I serve it up I just continued
to speak Portuguese yeah it was like a
break first yeah because I do feel like
well I do feel like that because that's
something that inhibited me yeah like
learning to speak French because
especially when you know when I was
learning French and then we had like all
these French speakers come in there and
I was like terrified to speak things I'm
like oh my god yes they're gonna laugh
at me and that's what Portuguese is not
like Spanish it's related okay I can
understand
pretty much everything in in in
Castilian Spanish or Castilian oh but
actually Portuguese is closer to
Romanian people can get about Romanian I
was one time listening to his [ __ ]
documentary and they had a bunch of lies
about the overthrow of Kutch ouch ouch
ouch ouch escu and I was sudden I'm wait
hold on I understood that like whoa whoa
whoa understood that and I realized that
Romanian is like Portuguese I didn't
know yeah I'm so fascinating I never
would have thought sex because I thought
that was like some kind of a Russian
language now it's a Romance language
it's part of it yeah of the Roman Empire
like the other Latin languages but it's
actually closer to Romanian I you know
what Romanian for a while I tried
learning Welsh I still like a bunch of
Welsh dictionaries and language tapes
and stuff like that and I got OK at it
but it's like that language is it
structurally it's kind of similar to
English in the word order and stuff like
that so I found that easier than French
because French everything is kind of
like versed and stuff like that but I
don't know if Welsh is like
it's really hard to because their
letters have like the drastically
different sounds than they do in English
and I found it really really hard to get
past that like every time you see like a
Y or a U or something like that it's
drastically different pronunciation I
was reading up you know on like you know
this is this is years back one time I
was reading up on like English
literature history and they were just
talking about how many different
versions of English there used to be oh
yeah they used to be like Kentish and
Northumbria and weird [ __ ] like that
they're all extinct now we've all
inherited what they called the King's
English
yeah and that was you know was you know
from Shakespeare you know handed or I
guess you could say the language that we
speak the English that we have now is
kind of like this Genesis was goes back
to Shakespeare yeah you know that was
the that was the English that the King
spoke the other English is are extinct
it's well I don't think they are
entirely because they're still like some
variations like when I was in the UK
even some people in Wales that were you
know bilingual they could speak English
and Welsh even they could told me that
they couldn't understand a goddamn word
the Scots were thing yeah well she's not
an English though no I'm not but there
were other English's yeah right I think
Northumbria in Kentish course don't
Hornet they were they were other forms
of I got some people still spent my
understanding I mean I don't know if
it's like their first language but you
know right it's just you know and then
there's Mississippi which is in English
all into itself and I only speak it when
I'm mad or when you talk to your dad but
you have to be on the phone for a while
like for yeah start coming out yeah
what's funny is that you know I was
telling one of my online showing one of
my online friends how people in
Mississippi Sound and where it came from
I was doing all all the history where
the dialect came from that I spoke it's
black well yeah well a lot of it what
happened was is it started out you know
the older forms of English were
basically kind of like an archaic former
British it was an era a lot of the stuff
that we say one time was it aristocratic
like eight was
just aristocratic thing and y'all and
yonder and Jess actually some
aristocratic British ship that's
obsolete now but we still use it
everybody makes a better people but what
happened was is that you know because
after reconstruction there were no jobs
only men worked women didn't work really
there were no jobs it was mostly white
men that were working like you know I
mean like actual real jobs everybody
else was just trying to survive
so um most most white babies were kind
of raised by little by black baby
sitters and nannies yeah and that's
where we learned to talk so kind of like
an Africanized version of english was
you know appeared and i was listening to
the recordings of black girl from
Mississippi and I'm listening to her
talking oh yeah I remember that so much
I'm listen to her than good that's how I
talk
yeah and I showed that somebody else and
that happened a lot like this house yeah
it's like it's definitely a hybrid just
like the coziness yeah all that fried
chicken and fries it lacks a cuisine
yeah what you know where there's a huge
huge African influence in the house and
not only and like I said in the food in
the language yeah everything white
southerners from like Mississippi
Louisiana Alabama Florida Panhandle up
and round you we're kind of like were
the American version of the Boer yeah
like South African Boers were kind of
like that kind of Africanized white
people yeah because that's kind of
because there was like so much like
crossing yeah all across over stuff but
yeah so what else did I have oh and also
I want to say that one of our previous
patrons Heather drastically increased
her support over the past week so we
really appreciate all of you guys you
know how much we love you also I got a
check in the mail a donation for the
show from someone named Marcus they have
sent me one for ya so thank you very
much we will take any and all monies
it's a trip we'll be sitting or all the
sudden we'll get like a check for 50
bucks no check it like 20 bucks I love
that though it's like that ya know just
like tip you know yeah
it's like I really appreciate that like
I said we didn't really I mean we
started this show like not necessarily
to make money off it we just like we're
like hey we're kind of funny wanted to
prove we like to talk and yeah wanted a
project to do we kind of became people
online and I and I said I write books
it's like maybe people will like want to
read my books if they get to know me and
stuff like that so the fact that some
people are now like they're sending us
all yeah like I'm saying like that guy's
Nana da who he's wearing sisters of
mercy shirts and [ __ ] he bought a brand
new net around he's got it he got eyes
showed him that I said that first last
and always album and he was he and his
Tina's family like [ __ ] blown away so
he started wearing that's it man always
old people are going minutes an awesome
shirt because they remember that yeah
that is that is awesome was always like
when I go like when I go out like when I
get an independent bar and I see like
some 20 year old and they're super into
like so she's your Bauhaus or something
like that and they know all the songs
and everything I'm like The Kids Are
Alright yeah then I showed him daughters
of Bristol oh okay yeah yeah who's like
his Sisters of Mercy I don't want to say
ripoff that sounds kinda like a tribute
Erick but they're like at Ricky's a
sequel band yeah yeah cuz they don't do
any covers yeah they do their own
original material but it sounds very
much like yes there's a mercy he has to
come on the show but he doesn't he
didn't say if he had any kind of
specialty yeah and then he invited you
on his show but we'll see what is
something we have to work out well it's
like who's got special we've only had
that we don't really only had three
official guests on yeah and they were
all famous they were writers or like dr.
price or we had an angry game oh yeah we
got him on three times yeah yeah we had
him on two or three times and I thought
he's read and didn't we have didn't we
have we have the guy that Merritt didn't
have Steve Merrill I did but we also had
we had the guy that was doing the the
Summerwind that's right it houses the
Summerwind restoration yeah that was a
while back right so actually you know
normal and we've had friends over during
our special specials but normally to
have a guest we kind of when we first
started the show we Jenny and I met
agreement between each other that we
would only have guests that were famous
yeah basically but that were you know I
mean that were relevant to some
topics that we were that we were talking
about either talking about that's what I
mean by famous yeah so if you do ever
want to come on the show this is this is
an offer to anybody and anybody can
contact us if you can come on the show
if you have a good topic to talk about
yeah we'll consider it and like I said
you don't got to be a specialist in
something yeah that would be helpful I
mean I'm not I'm not a specialist in
anything in particular well generally
I'm just kind of a general we're
generally shows about person all right
because I'm interested in lots of
different things right it has to be
something topical and you have to know
that topic and it has to be something
that the audience would be interested in
listening to yeah and then you can come
on
like I said crime be good anything yeah
true crime paranormal anything yeah
anything that's along that kind of
darker realm we can do it yeah but we
just have to get together and put the
show together yeah definitely correct um
also one more thank you to Dominic for
sending us a steelbook edition that's
right of John Carpenter's assault on
precinct 13 we will probably be
reviewing that Dominic Dominic's the
only [ __ ] that has given me what
I asked for which was a damn blu-ray
edition 70 DVDs but I understand it
because sometimes the the movies that
we're talking about it kind of old yeah
so they're mostly DVD and need to try to
get them on blu-ray a lot of them well
some of them are a pain in the ass for
their lyrics or it has to do with like
the [ __ ] aim a full book full blown
blu-ray yeah which thank you very much
Dominic yeah that's appreciated again
steelbook yes um and speaking of
blu-rays just today what the day that we
were recording this not that it was
going out but we just received the
blu-ray of the new Nicolas Cage H P
Lovecraft's got to see this adaptation
in the color out of space so that will
be will be reviewing that on matinee
show because that's new movies I hope I
hope it's good I'm very excited about
cage is just chewing the [ __ ] out of
that [ __ ] scenery I was I want to see
some Mandy type [ __ ] as crazy as that
[ __ ] can act ran he better put
that [ __ ] thing I love him though he
gets she got me a man Depot
Strega that she hid itself in the
bedroom this is so posted it's beautiful
I love Maddy do I have that on blu-ray I
think I do not I don't remember a future
you have so many I don't remember which
ones you have because sometimes you talk
about getting ones and then like I don't
know if you ever I don't know I gonna
reorganize some [ __ ] back here where we
where we're gonna start making Blucas
I'm getting so many blu-rays we gotta
have like a big place to put them
I probably need to buy another I need to
buy another yeah we need to rearrange
some [ __ ] cuz man actually we can eat
with the books and the eternal movie
selection back here yeah we probably
should cause like I said I forget like
what ones you have I have a [ __ ] ton of
DVDs and stuff like that to you it's
like silver we're up in the attic I
think I have enough for a [ __ ] rental
store those don't exist anymore yeah but
if they did if they did like we can open
one yeah yep all kind of stuff okay so
after all of those shoutouts did I even
say what this goddamn show was gonna be
about I mean it says in the title it
says in the title this shows about the
marquis de sade yeah
well i guess it's kind of relevant so I
was talking about taking French in
school even though I should note right
from the outset that I'm sure I'm going
to mangle all of these French names that
I'm gonna have to say so I apologize in
advance this is a topic relevant to me
and Jenny because we know all these
[ __ ] kinky s BDSM we've been to all
these clubs we know the [ __ ] the the
people in this in our local scene right
here and we this is where it all came
from the Marquis de Sade yeah
not like it wasn't happening before that
yeah but the fact that I mean the term
sadism was coined this guy you know
after his name I think it's just because
one he wouldn't shut up about it and
like he wrote so many books about it
that were so scandalous even today yeah
if you read the [ __ ] you're like I'm
that [ __ ] say god damn it yeah
he's kinky
he's kinky and he's not he's not any
nasty yeah he's nasty nasty the
[ __ ] was criminal really he was
yesterday he'd have been locked the [ __ ]
up well he was back then to his locked
up but today that he would have gotten
even harsher sentences he they never
would
dude free no he was a sexual offender
and rightly so predator all right and
and just the [ __ ] he was very
intelligent but I'm just kind of saying
dude was a piece of [ __ ] he was a P
would agree with that and the rapist
yeah but we're gonna get into this [ __ ]
and that's the thing it's like the
reason that I find the Marquis de Sade
fascinating and I think the reason that
a lot of people find him fascinating is
that he's a very complex character
because I think that people still seem
to think of like people as like you know
all good or all bad like very black and
white I know this guy could be either
thing it's like you know intellectuals
are like you know he you know advocated
for personal freedom and individuality
and like you know he was against the
strictures of the church and again and
that's good way because so he also
rationalized rape exactly that's what I
was just gonna say so it's like yes some
of the [ __ ] that he said is good and I
would agree with it but the fact that he
lived his life in the sense that it's
like oh individual freedom but it seem
like individual freedom for me and [ __ ]
you all [ __ ] everybody else I can just
do whatever I want to anybody it seemed
like he was rationalizing it was almost
like he wasn't a serial killer but he
had that kind of mentality would have
been one he I think he would have been a
bit maybe in this day and age yeah he
would have been and maybe if he hadn't
been in prison so much but it was the
only real life the only reason why he
wasn't killing the people back then is
because he knew that he didn't really
have to because if he got caught he
wouldn't do a whole lot of time yeah
because he was a net woman he was a
nobleman I mean in class and to be
honest with what he was doing was so far
beyond the pale the Society of that time
couldn't classify what he was doing they
didn't know how to deal with it that's
what I mean and the fact that you have
to think that the fact that noblemen in
particular were getting away with a lot
of [ __ ] that he was doing so the fact
that he was made an example of that he
was put in prison that he was so he must
have been either doing something way
that much worse or he was doing what
everyone else was doing but he wasn't
ashamed
of it and so he was just kind of like
really open about it so that caused you
know him to get into trouble he was kind
of ahead of his time he didn't realize
what he was doing was as nasty as well
maybe he did I think he did well no he
definitely did it was nowhere yeah he
just knew that he wouldn't really have
to pay the a modern price for it yeah
yeah and I mean yeah and another thing
is is that he was intellectualizing
everything see he was yeah rationalizing
he's making it philosophy into this and
it was new at the time it was society
wasn't familiar with what he was talking
about so he really wasn't being he
couldn't know what he was being
condemned for it but he wasn't being
condemned for it for the way a modern
person would be condemned right doing
this [ __ ] he was doing you'd be locked
up for life
and rightly so you'd be locked up for
life thank you for what he was doing
because like I said you know as as you
said as ahead of time he was it's like
he didn't see any difference between say
heterosexual heterosexuality and
homosexuality which you know that's very
modern um also yeah you know but the
fact of the matter is that as may be
ahead of the game as he was and some
people have even like attempted to say
that some of his novels particularly
Juliet were like early feminist texts
just because the female protagonist had
agency and was able to be like freely
just as horrible as a man and she was
causing suffering to others but the fact
of the matter is it's like yes personal
freedom is good yes individuality is
good yes we know that stuff nowadays but
I feel like he took it into the realm of
nihilism where he's basically and it's
weird because he tends to get lumped in
with you know the age of reason or the
you know the kind of the rationalist
words like Rousseau and stuff like that
but he was actually saying kind of
opposite because I mean Rousseau and
people like that who he was actually a
big fan of we're saying stuff like you
know humans are innately good whereas
desaad was saying no humans
innately cruel and that's good so - you
know so to go along with that cruelty -
you know indulge that cruelty is the
ultimate virtue right that's basically
what he was saying if in my experience
in general philosophers are craziest
[ __ ] all of them well you kind of have
to yeah a little bit mankind is not
innately good and as and mankind is not
innate legal yeah I don't think a wall I
don't think it's either one this is
neither one mankind is innately kind of
self-serving to a certain extent but
we're primates like chimpanzees and
gorillas you know which that's not a bad
thing that's a good thing because they
do kind of look out for their own - yeah
Isis operate the essence of a human
being is reciprocation
if yes yeah if you're good to a person
they tend to want to be good back to you
if you're bad to a person they're bad
back to you that's really how it works
it's just that simple so yeah that's
what I mean so I say okay so I think
that both both of the extremes are wrong
because it's clearly not right I mean
humans are a combination of both thing
for me the center is reciprocation yeah
you break a [ __ ] deal or you don't
reciprocate you're gonna pay yes best in
sin your interest to reciprocate yeah
somebody's nice to me I'm gonna be nice
to you yeah yeah you're bad to me I'm
bad to you yeah and that's just that's
more normal and most animals do they do
that
yeah which to me so to me that seems
that natural stance and natural so I
think people that say humans are
innately good or humans are innately
evil I think they're both wrong I think
they're all wrong all right
so in that sense you know yes you can
criticize you know some of the Age of
Enlightenment thinkers for saying that
humans are innately good but you can
also criticize - saw it for saying that
humans innately suck and so we should
just go along with that I don't buy it
and well another thing too is that's
kind of like the naturalistic fallacy
you know in the sense that just because
something happens in nature that that's
what's supposed to have it that's what
that's what we should do which um you
know like I said so I think he kind of
well
you're saying but we also had to say
well what is nature yeah and like I said
everything is more nuanced right and
it's kind of like the noble savage
concept that's not true either yeah okay
for instance you can go to the Great
Plains Indians alright they weren't a
noble savages there were just people oh
alright
they did the same crazy kind of [ __ ] the
white man did they just did their own
version of it yeah they had their own
weird religions their own will weird
belief systems they were more akin to
like pirates than they were anything
else we're gonna run on the plains and
raiding each other and taking things and
abducting women and killing women and
children you know I mean yes and a
pirate would do there wasn't any real
nobility in it it had to do it in their
circumstances the rules of the Great
Plains yeah in the same way there were
rules on the ocean yeah and they were
tribal yeah and people also react to
their immediate environment yeah like
you said to maximize their self-interest
right so reciprocation rata to play also
don't idealize human beings they're just
not like that there yeah I it's I mean
honestly and don't and don't [ __ ] on
them even though I mean we're just not
we're just people you're right and
everyone is pretty much the same and
there's also a certain kind of operating
system that all people kind of go
through now yes it's it's moderated by
cultures and traditions but if you
understand those cultures and traditions
you can predict pretty much how a person
will react yeah and I feel like you know
yes culture makes it heat makes you know
big difference but I don't think it
makes as much difference as people like
know even the racial differences most
people will react the same way given the
same stem exactly even even the racial
differences that are present in people
it really isn't enough to violate that
reciprocation that I was doing about if
you if you're nice to people no matter
who they are as long as they realized as
long as they can recognize that you're
being nice yeah
they will return it yeah pretty much a
world of unless so see
pass but that's pretty unless her so
yeah you just have which I think bar
kita thought was yeah he was a [ __ ]
circuit or associate big-time so yeah
because you know haven't grown up in
different cultures you know I've been
all over the world people reciprocate
you want to avoid culture clash like
when I was in Egypt there were certain
religious things that you didn't wanna
[ __ ] say yeah they're in a Muslim
country and they see they saw it in the
time that I was there they saw things in
religious terms and their concept of
religion was God of Abraham so when you
were dealing with a Muslim or a Bedouin
out in the middle of the [ __ ] Sinai
desert you wanted to go back to Old
Testament talk about Abraham you know
they like that kind of stuff you
wouldn't go with it with some fresh [ __ ]
like we're so or anything they didn't
understand that that's not their culture
well you just have to approach them on
there in turn right with respect and I
don't know like why that would be
controversial to say that because that
seems like all you need to do is just
have like a basic modicum of respect for
other people you have to understand that
other people are are engaging with the
world through their own lands yeah and
and just be aware of that Linden like
just right be cognizant of it it's like
that's it's not that hard right yeah so
yes so let's talk about the Marquis de
Sade
it's talk a little bit about his life so
now he was born an aristocrat obviously
he was born in 1740 in Paris now his
parents like his dad was a diplomat and
his mom was like a lady in waiting for a
princess so he was born in like this big
like palace um you know called Conde
which is the Royal House of Conde now
apparently from from everything that
I've read his dad he was a marquis de
sade this he was a chip off the old
black wicket of bluff because because
his uh his dad was very much
kind of a ho no but I mean so he was
like running around having affairs and
everything like that which not that
unusual for men at the time I guess you
know before we get too deep into this
for those of you have seen movies about
the Marquis de Sade
he's always cast as a sleek sexy
[ __ ] with a [ __ ] fantastic
mustache or a beard or some [ __ ] like
that okay when the Marquis was young he
was kind of an average guy looking yeah
well according to the drawings he was
okay looking yeah and he was kind of
small but by the time he was a
middle-aged man you're talking about
somebody who kind of looked like Ben
Franklin yeah he was kind of a fatty
there's a fat [ __ ] and he wasn't
all that attractive so he was indulgent
indulging in his you know listeners this
knot this knot makes some kind of like
an unrealistic internal view of who
[ __ ] the Marquis was because he's
been kind of errata sized over the years
by certain people weirdly it does seem
like that definite all right thank you
Tom I know it seems like well in 2000 I
think it was in 2000 they made a movie
about him well at least about his final
years called quills and Geoffrey Rush
was in it who's a you know a fairly
attractive actor and they had him it was
kind of like his final years like in the
insane asylum and the weird thing about
them it's a good movie but the weird
thing about the movie was that not only
did it really dramatize like how he died
but it also sort of made him into a
martyr to free speech and intellectual
freedom that's not what he which I'm not
sure that's the angle that I would take
come on
I'm just saying and you know what I mean
it's like and I'm not saying that his
book should be banned because they were
for a long time you know those are just
words on a page that's not gonna hurt
anybody I don't think that they should
be burned or banned or know anything or
censored or anything like that but I'm
talking about him as a person and the
[ __ ] that he did yeah you know that
needs to be separated from because you
know he was as a person he was not a
good person
no and I read a collection of his works
this is years ago it's just porn really
and in a way it gets kind of like gross
and tedious let me sum prison he was
writing porn he's passing it out through
the damn bars I guess well he was
basically sticky well a lot he made
money his stuff wasn't published until
later and like after he died like a lot
of the stuff that he wrote in prison I
don't think he ever intended it I
remember I remember that he was writing
it from what I read he was writing it
while he was in the best deal and handed
it out through the bars and he had
accomplices selling it and then from the
proceeds he was able to buy stuff when
he's in prison that's how I remember um
he did that a little bit but see the
thing about it I think a lot of people
don't know this because he's mostly
known for like the gross ass porn but he
wrote a lot of other [ __ ] too like just
regular normal gameplays he wrote a
travelogue and some of that stuff well
that's all anybody read I don't even
think any of his other stuff like has
survived what interesting is you're like
damn they were thinking about that in
the 1700s they were it's like if you
read it now it's you know it's really
funny I was reading a [ __ ] article
earlier today in the independent the
British newspaper and it was by the two
guys that had done like a more recent
like translation of 120 days of sodom
you know because they were translating
it out of French they were translating
into English and the the hilarious thing
and I guess this never occurred to me
but they're like so when you're
translating something like this that's
basically just like all porn and just
like all [ __ ] and shit-eating and
everything like that yeah he's like so
we're sitting there trying to decide so
he's like so I'm sitting here having
this conversation with the other guy
that he's translating this was like well
okay well when he uses this French word
it's like should we use dick or [ __ ] or
brick or it's like when they use this
where should we use tits or should we
use it it's like they're having to like
they're like we don't want it to sound
too modern because it was written in the
1700s but it's like we don't want it to
we don't want it to sound too nice
either because it's supposed to be porn
in the books weird [ __ ] was happening
like you got some virgin for gentle
[ __ ] noble check thee that you've
abducted and you're you [ __ ] had sex
with her against her will that suck at
rape well not at all you call one
manservants in who has this [ __ ]
gigantic [ __ ] and he's got syphilis and
you make him have sex with her and give
her sniffling give her syphilis and then
you sew her shut
yeah so it did so the [ __ ] sticks and
she's gonna catch it I mean if that's
what we're talking this is messed up
yeah it's like it's not just [ __ ] and
orgies it's like oh it's [ __ ] torture
and [ __ ] there's torture there's a
shitty there's a lot of [ __ ] making
people swallow farts okay
evening vomit it's like this all kind of
it like that yeah I mean here's okay now
in 120 days of sodom one of the
characters is one of the prostitutes is
like this old lady who it said has never
wiped her ass ever day no she has like a
what they describe and it's described
because I've read this portion of it out
of her butt is like a like a volcano
like so like a little mountain of [ __ ]
and it says in there like the marquis de
sade it is like so even like [ __ ] from
her infancy still clung there because
she had never wiped her ass ever so this
is the [ __ ] this is what work this is
the level of show and look I would get a
file he was super into blood stuff well
I'm the sodomy was like his that was his
main thing that was like the ideal thing
yeah yeah so everything was like every
thought he and he didn't care men women
children he didn't give a [ __ ] just like
and it was if there was an orphan like a
butthole he would yeah I remember there
was interracial stuff there was
bestiality there was [ __ ] everything
don't let you have we covered all all of
these [ __ ] covered all of the bases
yeah he even nowadays you read the [ __ ]
and you're like okay you're like man
come on okay right yeah and if had
because upbringing and what he was
trying to prove and here's the day
electronic roof like I always said like
I was saying to Tom it's like look it's
like I've read like portions of the book
I never sat down to read the whole thing
I mean a lot of people don't know but a
hundreds what 20 days of Sodom is the
book it's not a complete book like what
happened was when he was writing it and
I'll get into this in a little bit when
he was right
he only wrote the introduction and like
the first section that he finished the
rest of it was just like notes now they
were really detailed notes so they've
been able to like kind of cobble
together something from that but it
wasn't entirely finished he was planning
on finishing it later but yeah so I told
I was like and I've never been able to
sit through the entire like movie of
salò the 120 days of South by a what's
his name like payload Pasolini or
whatever it is from the 70s because look
I can watch I love horror movies I can
watch gore I can watch all kind of
uncomfortable [ __ ] like all day long but
the second somebody starts eating poop
or vomit I'm out I'm out that's like
pretty much the only thing I can't watch
I don't like PE either but it's like you
know what I mean I can stomach that I
can stuff stomach watching people throw
up and stuff like that but it's
something you know like the end of
audition where like he's like eating
vomit out of a bowl it's like this I'm
like ho no thanks funny is that oh thank
you what's funny is that I have no
reaction I don't have no reaction to
that for some reason I don't know it's
like I said I can watch and I can even
watch like real life like surgery yeah
you know I can watch like dead bodies
being kind of part about autopsies and
[ __ ] like that I can watch all that it
doesn't bother me but the second
somebody like starts doing some [ __ ]
with poop yeah I'm out of there it's
funny I don't really have any reaction
to that
this isn't I don't know why I just both
that's why I couldn't that's why I
couldn't sit through the human centipede
like in one sitting I was just gonna
keep getting up it was tripping because
I was like I'm [ __ ] I'm just gagging
and it's like I have to go over here and
stop gagging for a minute before I go
back it just makes me like some reason I
just didn't have any reaction to it I
don't know why the poop and vomit just
grosses me out
so although I was very amused by the the
old prostitute in 120 days of sodom with
the volcano of [ __ ] stuck to her but
yeah they should never kind of got she'd
never wiped her ass
now you're gonna be singing about
imagining all like weekend you never
wipe your ass a volcano forms I never
thought of that
well Marquis de Sade thought of that
[ __ ] yeah he thought of all this I don't
know if that would really happen but a
lot of the [ __ ] that he's raised would
never wipe their asses
and they don't have a [ __ ] volcano
sticking out of their asses I hope not
yes it's like he just liked he just
liked the sound of it he's like yeah
volcano shaking [ __ ] up yeah I thought
of the best idea ever
so yeah um slap the [ __ ] out of it so it
seemed like like I said he his dad was
kind of similar to him he was kind of a
like a libertine and [ __ ] like that
you [ __ ] yeah pretty much to an extent
where his mom who was also kind of an
absent parent I mean as a lot of
aristocrats we're back in the day they
kind of leave they'd have the kid then
they'd come in the maybe back up take
care of let me back up a little bit and
kind of explain to the audience in case
you don't know what an aristocrat was
all right nowadays in the united against
[ __ ] that laid around and then
okay [ __ ] me what I was saying was is
that nowadays in the United States you
have people on welfare they'll get a
check from the government and you know
they might not do anything that was buy
some stuff and live in the house in
Europe back in the seventeen hundreds a
nobleman was the [ __ ] same thing they
didn't do anything they just get a check
from a king except they actually had
enough money to do something yeah but it
was enough to done like people on well
some weird [ __ ] it's like a high-end
welfare that's exactly what it is yeah
it's like a high-end welfare which is to
the American mind-boggling it's a
boggling [ __ ] you put the you you
have rich people on welfare and their I
end well and like I said I would rather
have poor people on welfare because at
least I mean they don't give them enough
to like really live on there at least
live very well but these people lived in
like huge palaces yeah they're going
around kidnapping women and raping them
and [ __ ] like that getting off because
they had like a whole bunch of money
[ __ ] yeah maybe I some [ __ ] think about
it
[ __ ] that you think about that [ __ ] look
at what this [ __ ] got away with
go up to the king and go hey I'm a count
gave me my check yeah I'm actually make
me a Duke of something don't wanna I'm
off a bigger check Duke of something
yeah Duke yes I do that Duke of Earl
they got the right people
on welfare yeah it's that's awesome well
they thought it was on tape that was
awesome but don't like the French
Revolution I'm like your head behind is
my mind is boggled well because I feel
like an Marquis de Sade sure I had this
mindset also they kind of felt like well
that was their birthright yeah they felt
like they were like a cut above almost
like they were a different I don't know
if they'd save there were a different
species than poor people but I feel like
that's probably where they were so if
you're poor and you're all welfare
you're living like a [ __ ] nobleman
yeah probably basic one welfare would be
like yeah yeah yeah yeah I wish I could
afford something more than ramen noodles
thank you no I can't except in what
state you live in some of them have
[ __ ] nice cars and all everything
I've never seen that yeah
Oh actually no we have some friends that
are kind of on welfare look pretty good
I don't know he was doing pretty good
for not working me you know I she's not
as good as eyes I was gonna say that I
guess yeah but she didn't do anything
yeah well yeah that was like a
shitty-ass apartment yeah we used to go
pick her up sometimes it was all kind of
sketchy [ __ ] like I said Rex is
dealing crack yeah so it's like oh you
say no she lived really great if I could
it was after the old day she turned her
daughter living in a [ __ ] crack back
in the day should have been a countess
it's not the same I mean these people
okay so so he's born in this [ __ ]
palace essentially because his mom is a
lady-in-waiting and his dad as a
diplomat so um his dad was essentially
like such a [ __ ] that eventually his mom
was just like [ __ ] all this I'm going to
a convent now one thing that happened
when the Marquis was young um he wasn't
really raised by his mom as a lot of
aristocrats weren't like they were
raised by nannies and various other
people's servants and whatnot
one thing that was remarks upon a lot
when he was a kid and maybe this was
very common for aristocrats children
because they're kind of like given
everything and all of their whims are
indulged so they said by the time that
he was four years old he was a horrible
horrible brat like he was just like
he knew that he could get whatever he
wanted and he was just like really
tyrannical and he was just you know what
I mean what's a lot of for your alright
even ones that are not aristocracy but
when he was I believe six years old his
mom had tried to like get him to be
little friends with like the prince you
know like the prints are the princes
baby or whatever it was like the same
age and apparently the Marquis decided
like beat up on the prince and they had
to send the Marquis away to live with
like an uncle who was an Abbe and at or
an abbot rather a days they would say in
French did I even say that Marquis de
Sade is obviously not his name that's
his title his title his name is actually
Donna Tian Alphonse Francois that is his
name desaad that's what's my middle name
name is Francois well well it's Francis
it is it's right it means principle yes
balli
my middle name is hope actually yeah
case anyone was interested but yeah so
he gets when he's about six years old he
gets sent off to live with his uncle who
was an Abbott now according to some
sources that I saw it might have been
right around this time that he started
to develop what would later become his
hatred for the church in general and his
you know readiness to point out their
hypocrisy because apparently this Abbey
this Abbott that he went to live with
even though he was supposedly like a
clergyman and everything was a total
man-whore and also just like didn't like
was preaching about one thing over here
and then like doing all this like
licenses but [ __ ] over here like a you
said licenses do you
yeah like a you said that you're drunk
already
yeah it's so early I'm not gonna make
patty melts for the break I know in the
break we're gonna make some patty melts
I mean yeah i IE twon't and we're still
it's like olivine among that but yeah so
he doesn't wait I am well yeah [ __ ]
getting skinny on me
getting a waste like that booting
titties when I can I can't talk about it
I know he's going all like we're talking
about the Marquita side so yeah so so it
might have been something like this like
him seeing like clergymen engaging in
like you know going to prostitutes all
the time and [ __ ] like that that kind of
got him thinking oh well they're all
hypocrites because that was something
that he said later on and like I said
that was one of the things that he wrote
that I could get on board with cuz it's
true and I could see how him pointing
out hypocrisy got him into trouble but
like I said the [ __ ] that he did is not
excusable even though I do like agree
with some of the [ __ ] that he said this
goes all the way back to Mississippi and
Baptist Church and everything
everybody's always known was the best
[ __ ] happened in the churches mm-hmm if
you were a pervy [ __ ] the first
thing you want to do is try to get get
into a church because you'd have access
and you would have cover yeah you have
la Brisa you can't attack me I'm [ __ ]
part of the [ __ ] Baptist Church yeah
it's just been going on for centuries
Dennis knows all about that yeah yeah it
doesn't I'm not gonna say anything bad
about religion I like all religions I'm
a myth assist I'm a Christian myth
assist I don't believe you guys should
happen but I like it I like yeah well I
like it in the sense that the same sense
that I say right Greek mythology and
there is and just like Joseph Campbell
says there's a certain power in
mythology yeah you know I mean [ __ ]
saying the Lord's Prayer as you approach
death it's the same thing as kind of
like [ __ ] [ __ ] you know like like a
Comanche Indians [ __ ] death song you
don't I mean when you know that your
time is sort and all that yeah III
totally understand
I totally understand it I did I know you
do
well I been there you know talking about
[ __ ] when you come close to it you
know that I mean you're gonna need
something to believe in and it carries
you through yeah and it doesn't mean
this false it also doesn't mean that
it's real is
just means that it's true for you it's
yeah and everything is subjective and
everything has to do at the time yeah
demotion humans are very emotional yeah
yeah I don't I don't believe any of that
stuff but I feel like I stay alive out
of spite but that's another emotion well
yeah that's another that's another I'm
just saying it doesn't you don't need
like you don't need necessarily like a
you know kind of a religious thing or
like a spiritual thing or anything like
that it's just whatever you believe in
yeah yeah like a subjective yeah that's
my that's my overriding emotion that's
just like because you know all right so
so like I said this this kind of like
gave him an early education in hypocrisy
the hypocrisy of the church as he
perceived it yeah the autocracy that's
going on to this day well yeah that's
what I made new stuffs coming out about
those [ __ ] right so like I said this
is something this is something that I
can get on board with him because I'm
you're not anti-catholic there's all I
[ __ ] love the Catholic style and I
mean the way those churches are
decorated the songs the [ __ ] decorum
and everything well yeah every time I go
to a city in Europe I always get all
them oh yeah that's the most gothic of
all [ __ ] that's the most English yeah
you know I mean I totally understand I
understand there they're there even if
you don't believe it it's like you know
just go like I'm just looking at cuz
it's a great show it's a great show and
man I would love to have like a Catholic
[ __ ] ceremony of any kind yeah burial
wedding whatever the shits fancy [ __ ]
it's just [ __ ] fence yeah
that's really all it is very you know in
case you're new to the show I'm very
educated on Christianity was raised as a
Christian Christian military academy
Christianity is a bunch of memes alright
and and it's a song and it's a certain
Gestalt it's a style I understand it
well it's a subculture yeah yeah there's
bridle chair we all have our own yeah I
know kind of signifiers right right
right so I'm not against it but we know
what's going people are abusing this
[ __ ]
you know why we can't have nice things
you have nice things about the [ __ ]
gonna infiltrate it is there's only
there's a small percentage people just
[ __ ] it up forever you're gonna [ __ ] it
up for everybody else go run after other
people's children and this [ __ ] spills
going on all the way back to the 1700s
in the [ __ ] the Mark II saw it and
he's like these dudes are fake yeah
everybody's really disappointed in it
yeah it's hard to be a priest I can be
you know and I can be on board with him
for that for it cuz like was a very
vocal atheist when that was something
you did not do um you know so I respect
that like I said but he was still a
terrible person even though I said oh
yeah we're not making him a good guy no
saying even though like I did agree with
some things that he said that doesn't
mean that I thought he was awesome cuz
now I think he was a [ __ ] yeah but
yeah so behind bars he did yeah and and
like I said you know rightfully so he
was actually he spent I think more than
30 years of his life you just wouldn't
be able to trust him around your wife
he'd rape your wife he'd rape your
daughters he might no matter how young
they were or your son or your senior you
just could not trust this you could not
leave anyone unattended around them ever
no ever know today he would old ladies
old men yeah children yeah cats dogs
Jesus Christ yeah today he'd have been
he didn't in prison today yeah I mean
yeah yeah like I said by any measure by
any measure so because he was kind of
like from an aristocratic family so he
gets he goes into the military now I
believe he was like put in there he
became I think a sub-lieutenant when he
was 14 or 15 years old and he later like
became a colonel and he actually like
served in the seven years more um and
after that so which a lot of aristocrats
did but they were able to get kind of
high up positions because of their money
and whatnot um so after after the Seven
Years War was over what ended up
happening was that so the desaad family
while socially very prominent um didn't
have maybe as much money as some of the
other aristocrats and this happened a
lot it's like they were still your name
still meant something but sometimes the
ancestors had kind of squandered some
air yeah
when this goes back to what I was saying
I said if you're on welfare you're
living like a nobleman a lot of these no
woman's didn't have any [ __ ] money
yeah I mean they didn't have money
obviously but not enough to own anything
right that's what I was talking about
especially something as small as a
Marquis a Marquis was a nobody
in terms of [ __ ] royalty it's kind of
like there was a Duke or a Duchess they
had some [ __ ] in the DAAD family baron
and their line is still around nowadays
cuz I'll get into that at the end of the
show because I've found a couple
articles about that that was really
interesting but um apparently in that
like the male heirs it would go marquis
count marquis count marquis count
marquis yeah like that's how they did it
um so and like I said this line is still
around today so when he gets out of the
war so what ended up happening there was
that he fell in love with this younger
girl from like this wealthy family
however he like went to the went to the
girl's dad and like wanted to marry into
that family and the dad was like well
you can't marry her but you can marry
her older sister because the older
sister was the one that was gonna
inherit the money she was like next in
line and it happened that this family
the montreux family they had more money
than the decides but they didn't have
the social status so it was kind of a
win-win so um so the Marquis ends up
marrying this woman named Renee pillaji
montre de montreuil that was her family
name so even though this was like a
marriage of convenience and a marriage
like to kind of like you know a mutual
benefit for both families and later on
and I'll kind of get into this but his
wife apparently like participated in
some of the [ __ ] that he was up to no of
course um you know what I mean she had
these predilections if you ask me well
no because it was just in a rate he
wanted to marry the younger sister okay
so they arranged it
but the dad said no why don't you marry
this one why is the way I interpreted
the way I interpreted it is that the
wife was kind of tolerant at least for a
certain period
she was for a long time
um now it's weird because they did a
documentary on the murky decide for the
biography channel and I watched that a
couple of times I watched another one
that was done like a British one and
then I've read like a whole bunch of
different sources interestingly the
documentary on biography did not mention
that the wife they kind of said oh well
the wife put up with it for a long time
and she did seem to love him and blah
blah blah she did divorce him later but
it was like a long time in the future
however most of the other sources that I
read said the wife not only tolerated it
but maybe participated or at least just
let it happen
they don't know if she was like watching
the [ __ ] or if she was participating in
the [ __ ] but she didn't stop it she knew
what he was doing you know what I mean
so I'm not really sure what her
involvement was but they do have like
some letters between the two of them
have survived because like I said he was
in jail like a lot so they wrote back
and forth to each other they did
actually seem to have like some you know
warm feelings or some love for each
other um but I don't know how complicit
she was in all of the [ __ ] that he did
she knew what he was up to though and it
was some illegal [ __ ] and she didn't do
anything to saba shoot him report him
she didn't do nothing like that
so take of that makeup that what you
well now they did eventually end up
having three children two sons and one
daughter now I wouldn't trust that
mother hook around any any kids
including his own know now but I don't
think I've seen anything that he where
he like did anything to his own kids but
it should be noted that after he died
his son must have hated one of his sons
must have hated the [ __ ] out of him
because after he died he had all of a
[ __ ] burned like all of his they you
know some of his shits arrived obviously
but he had like all of his manuscripts
that he found there I wish there were
some [ __ ] up with him it might have been
because like I said he really didn't
seem to have any compunction about I
mean he thought that the ultimate virtue
was just like doing whatever the [ __ ]
you wanted and damn the consequences or
like not caring about anyone else like I
said that's sociopathy but I don't think
he would have seen it that way because
it
does seem that he was aware that it's
weird because it seems like he was aware
that as an aristocrat he had gotten used
to treating everyone else like an object
for his own use so he seemed like he was
aware of that but he still did it anyway
and didn't feel bad about it and in fact
he almost seemed to like you know kind
of laud that you know like make kind of
a philosophy out of that whole idea yeah
that's exactly what he was doing it's
very odd like to read him because it
seems contradictory but I don't know
like you can see how someone that was
raised that way well he had that kind of
nobility attitude of where you're here
for me yeah he did have it and I'm gonna
do what I want to you and that's and you
can't complain and why are you
complaining about it because he's happy
about that's your station in life and he
definitely did feel like he was superior
and which a lot of aristocrats did yeah
not a lot of them did [ __ ] to the extent
that the Marquis decided or at least
didn't write about it like he did maybe
they were all doing jelly there's a lot
of stuff in the American kind of like um
Declaration of Independence that [ __ ]
kind of calls out the European nobility
and their idea of that they were like a
born of a different means there was a
lot of European nobles thought that they
weren't created by natural means that
they were created by God
that's right again that's a weird [ __ ]
that's so that's what they mean by by
all men's being created equal what that
meant and back in those days is that we
were all created by sex yeah we all came
out of vagina right don't get all uppity
but a lot of nerd a lot of European
nobles didn't see it that way they were
kind of considered themselves to be
created by supernatural means through
their interpretation of the Bible that's
some weird yeah like an angel brought
that was like right yeah that their
parents created by sex they were created
by God
that's some weird [ __ ] when you think
about it well yeah they definitely they
definitely did seem to see them
selves as a race apart a species apart
either well that's because the way they
interpreted the way they interpreted
stuff in the old of the New Testament is
that God created nobles and Kings to
rule over you yeah okay they were
created you sing away other people were
created
oh they fell that dirty filthy humping
[ __ ] right but not the nobles and not
the kings and not the royal people they
were created by God so really a lot of
that all men being created equal
yeah that was a it was they were talking
about they were saying that they were
seeing all people are created by natural
means yeah so get the [ __ ] over you go
[ __ ] over yourself unstated but impious
so yeah so obviously since he was an
avowed libertine his marriage I believe
he married when he was about 23 years
old um none none of us stopped any of
his sexual proclivities so a couple
months into his marriage he starts an
affair with this actress named la voix
faux salt he also started an affair with
his wife's sister who was the one that
he had wanted to marry to start with he
also started buying other properties
where he would hire prostitutes and take
him to these properties now even though
the women are prostitutes and they're
being paid for their services the [ __ ]
that he did to them was not okay y'all
he's doing that Bateman [ __ ] from like
American Psycho with him yeah can't read
that book that deserve it and yet
American Psycho is a very Saudi and yeah
yeah because basically even though year
like I said even though you're paying a
prostitute for her services okay it's
like once you start doing some [ __ ] that
she didn't agree to then that shit's not
go straight yeah and that's essentially
what he was doing he would like bring
you bring the prostitutes to the house
under you know oh we're just gonna do
like you know sex like a slice to what
[ __ ] and then like when they get there
either drugs them ties them up and all
of a sudden and then like starts
whipping them and she
now he would have them with him too
because he was like apparently a
masochist as well as a sadist was a
sadomasochistic yeah he liked to deliver
pain he liked to receive it so you
talking about I could Albert Fish style
[ __ ] like did we do a show about
our profession we did a show on our yeah
you can go back to that one that was
that like I said that's why nowadays I
feel like Markie decided be like he
would be on like every [ __ ] predator
list yeah because he has the very even
if he didn't kill anybody and he may
very well have and they didn't find out
about it it's possible but he definitely
has that type of mindset and he has that
type of like I said that type of
rationalization of why he does the
things he does and he's almost trying to
like make it into some like highfalutin
yeah philosophical trying to he's trying
to make it [ __ ] like st. amant
sanctimonious yeah and it's like it's
just it's funny to read it nowadays cuz
I was like I'm just stop just stop it
it's like you just want to like rape
people and torture people and act like
it's like something like an Egyptian
wouldn't to be tortured and to be raped
because we're talking about dude that
would he'd take it up the ass too you
know don't so gonna say like I said he
didn't really he just his mission in
life he was like Albert Fish yeah his
mission in life was just to break every
taboo every stricture against morality
yeah it was a religious element he was
mad at his disappointment or the good of
the church if he asked me well which is
very much my second way to yeah that's a
lot like our fish our fish thought that
he could do whatever he wanted to anyone
children and women and eating little
girls and rape and little girls and boys
he could do that if he wanted to as long
as he paid for it like Jesus did so he'd
stick needles up in himself and [ __ ]
they were when they electrocuted him he
stood needles up in his taint time do
that sticking needles so deep in himself
he couldn't get it out and that's paying
for those sins look mark Siddall
masochism that's that's which like I
said I'm at ISM and masochism that's
mark you decide
yeah I don't see that's the thing and
that's where I think a lot of you know a
lot of people that maybe
of lionize him a little bit I don't
think it's as common especially not in
the United States because in the u.s.
he's usually seen as a villain but it
does seem like I don't have a problem
with a lot of the sexual stuff that he
did as long as the people were
consenting it's like if people are
consenting and of age do whatever the
[ __ ] you want
oh yeah we know them that's what I mean
it's like each other et people [ __ ] on
as long as you brush your teeth after
where I don't really care as long as
everyone as long as everyone is on the
same page right you just get up to
whatever you want is I don't have a
problem with that at all the problem I
have with him is that he would kidnap
people he would rug people he would tie
them up against their will he would do
[ __ ] against people it was a [ __ ]
rapist yeah and that's a rapist and now
it's the same thing [ __ ] more [ __ ]
fish was doing yeah they said it was
children and he was killing them and
here's the deal I think if the Marquis
had seen Alber fish he wouldn't had a
problem with that I don't think he would
have either okay okay because I'm even
Arashi why you would harass him you know
it like for example in 120 days of sodom
which is a fictional this is a novel you
know the dudes in that story who are for
like kind of higher up looks like a
banker and a bishop and all this other
kind of stuff now they torture these
their children children teenagers they
torture them and do it and they murder
them now I'm not saying that Markie
decided anyone in real life if it like I
said he may very well have I'd you know
I don't know I've never heard of it but
you know that's a fictional novel but I
do feel like the fact that he wrote that
as a fantasy kind of makes me feel like
that somebody that did it in real life
that he would be okay with that
yeah sure you would because the weird
the weird thing about evil like fish I
think he probably would not the weird
thing about him though is that he was
very like I said he's a complicated
person
he was very against the death penalty
because he saw that as an authority the
state like you know imposing their will
on a person and that
wasn't allowed but he didn't have a
problem with murder like someone just
murdering someone because they wanted to
or because that person he's talking
about the EU yeah the European death
penalty they were killing people for
nothing well yeah for [ __ ] that you know
I mean it was a very you know what's
very important that's what I mean you do
have to understand him in the context of
his time time right so it's maybe when
you look at it through that lens it's
not as weird because it does sound weird
to say oh well you know he was against
the death penalty but then he was okay
with murder but he saw them as two
different things and like I said he was
very was England was hanging people who
are basically [ __ ] minor offenses
well in and as we'll get into in a
little bit I mean even in France back
then in the 1700s sodomy was punishable
by death
yeah and whether you were gay straight
is it a matter you go in the but if they
catch you they're good although in
practice yeah they didn't actually do it
it was usually only I believe I saw
something that said only like five
people were actually burning right take
for that but they would usually add it
on to charges like other charges right
and then they would end up burning you
at the stake for other charges is you
know Danna would hit weird ways to
[ __ ] rationalizing their laws back
then yeah well they didn't always follow
their own laws yeah well who does it
like that's kind of what happens I'm not
saying we shouldn't have laws obviously
you should but it's like we hit this
thing we're dealing white people there's
a few white people will kind of make up
laws and then not follow them or they're
like get around like get around out
there versus you right you you can't
really take laws that seriously in
European culture there's because a law
said something didn't necessarily mean
to that that's what that's what I mean
it's it's one thing that it was on the
books it's another thing because I mean
she didn't actually apply on some places
in the u.s. you have some laws that are
still on the books that are not
informing these Mississippi us could get
locked up for doing laundry on the wrong
[ __ ] day yeah that's never gonna be
an obviously I think in some states are
some counties in the US sodomy is still
technically illegal yeah but that's
never gonna be it but no one's gonna
know no one's
in for Santa what are they gonna do like
look in your [ __ ] window with a
telescope yeah and I guarantee doing
some butt stuff and I guarantee you the
average lawyer in those states but can
they don't even [ __ ] know about those
laws they do probably is why the [ __ ]
would anybody they would know we got
real problems so it's kind of like the
same thing back then look the concept of
law and order and courts is actually
kind of new and it's experimental Europe
Europe and just America to operate it
mostly on tradition more than it did law
yeah yeah no yeah they had laws they
weren't always evenly applied yeah just
depending on the situation
why isn't what it's cracked up to be
you could get a route you could get we
didn't really have cops yeah until like
what the 30s like twenties or thirties
and and in the cop of the twentieth of
the 30s would like a [ __ ] Mike a mall
cop or something
yeah really they were only like what is
it Frank Hamer here [ __ ] you know I
mean it's maybe some of the elite
policeman you could probably consider
them cops but you could get rid of all
this stuff today and it really wouldn't
make a big difference I don't think not
all the time not in the big picture but
go ahead Jay well actually we're over
we're like an hour and fifteen minutes
or something like that so maybe we
should stop and take a break we're gonna
fresh drinks yeah maybe grab a bite to
eat right and then come back and second
half a show talk a little bit more about
the Marquis de Sade yeah so stay tuned
you guys what not I said we're gonna be
we have enough time to wrap up his story
in the second half yeah we'll see how
long it takes like I said so we'll be
back in just a few minutes the hell's
going on here
fight in a minute ago
what are you guys doing downtown you
love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
Oh okay break is done
I fed everybody we have patty milk
yeah Patty Mills is a good patty Mullin
is really good medium rare
diced onions cheese pickles yeah I love
big Thousand Island dressing on [ __ ]
artisanal bread yeah it was lovely yeah
done in the pan soaking up all that
alcohol we also got two more alcoholic
drinks I'm actually drinking usually I
have screwdrivers I was out of vodka I
didn't realize yes however I mean I did
have a bottle that I had forgotten that
I bought one time ago Jim Beam Apple yes
it's good
turns out Jim Beam apple orange juice
tastes just fine I tried it for it I was
like that's good I never thought about
mixing those two things before but it's
actually like a sex on the beach yeah
it's actually pretty good it's kind of
sweet but you know I like Jim Beam Apple
I know that's like probably cool yeah
I'm drinking Red Bull citrus with a
splash of lime a splash of orange silver
tequila there you go yeah real good so
we have like a little bit different
drinks than normal all right so when we
left we were talking about the marquis
de sade and how he had married for money
you know and for familial kind of [ __ ]
and how he was also like banging the
wife's much younger sister also he had
another at least one other apartment in
Paris where he would take all the
prostitutes now for many years he would
hire prostitutes bring them to these
apartments do horrible things to them
sexual assault I mean essentially now he
got a reputation and this is like the
this to me this kills me because as I
said aristocrats you could get away with
a lot as long as you kept [ __ ] on the
down-low yeah like don't go around like
flaunting it or anything so I don't know
well the laws were weird
yeah like sodomy and things like
having sex with people you weren't
married to what'd he call it adultery
adultery that might be illegal that
doesn't mean you can't do some [ __ ]
wild ass [ __ ] because there was stuff
that the law hadn't thought up and they
were doing that and people with money I
mean that is now yeah people with money
can get away with pretty much anything
unless you're too like egregious or too
like open about it which I think was the
Marquis de Sade's problem now what ended
up happening during this time period was
that he was hiring prostitutes so much
and doing so much horrible [ __ ] to them
against their will like essentially as I
said you know he'd get them to the house
and that he would like tie them up or
drugged them or whatever
and beat them up and do [ __ ] that they
didn't agree to and so many of them
reported him that not only was he put
under police surveillance like they
[ __ ] didn't arrest him at the time
but they watched him also the
authorities told all the Paris brothels
in the area not to send him any more
prostitutes yeah that's how bad it was
and he was doing weird [ __ ] based on
memory you know what I read a long time
ago he would have he would have this
manservant he had this well that's that
comes about a little bit that coming
later yet he had his manservant who was
I guess was bisexual is what you want to
call him you know is how he how he chose
him and he'd call hookers over and do
weird [ __ ] to them like whip them and
get them to enact like religious stuff
to make them act like nuns and they
would make them pray and then there'd be
like crucifix and they was like step on
crucifix on Emerson right and then he'd
like flip it around to where you know
he's Jesus and that there's all kinds of
weird [ __ ] which in a way it's almost
kind of like yeah he was getting in
trouble for like abusing the prostitutes
but it almost seemed like at the time
like the blasphemy was mayor Dale yeah I
think there were that seemed to like a
feminist sensibilities of people at
large he were more mad about the jesus
angle I think they were too it seems
like the blasphemy was a bigger deal
than the actual abusing of human beings
and he was an equal-opportunity [ __ ]
over I mean he would even put himself
he'd have that he'd have the prostitutes
whip him and put stinging nettle on him
while he was being Jesus and then he
would like jerk off to Jesus and then
put Jesus up in his booty I mean it was
just it was [ __ ] weird it's like the
kind of [ __ ] that [ __ ] Alber fish was
into that's what I mean in a way like I
can see why some why some intellectuals
or some like modern people might admire
him for his breaking of taboos some of
which are [ __ ] and there was no
reason for them to be a taboo because
what business is it of anyone's the
problem with him like I said the why
he's such a problematic figure is that
yeah even though he had some good ideas
yes some of those taboos needed to be
broken yes like you know it's good that
he opened that discussion into various
fetishes and everything like that and
some of that [ __ ] was okay as long as it
was consenting people but the problem
was a lot of the [ __ ] that he was doing
was not with consenting people you know
what I mean
yeah it was weirder than that though too
because you look at it this way he was
defending the church yeah and in those
days that was [ __ ] very dangerous
ground because the church it the church
in in Europe in the seventeen hundreds
was kind of like the equivalent of the
federal government the European
monarchies you know I mean the royal
families was kind of like state
governments and overseeing them was this
[ __ ] Catholic empire this church it'd
be kind of like committing a federal
offense yeah is what he was doing you
know I mean it doesn't that doesn't
exist today that's long gone in Europe
but back in his day what he was doing
was kind of like the equivalent of
making federal offenses
yeah and in some ways I feel like even
though he did get in trouble for abusing
people it was more about that gee I feel
like yeah I feel like the blasphemy was
perceived as a bigger deal at the time
that's why he got in trouble because
like I said a lot of aristocrats were
doing similar kind of [ __ ] to what I was
doing to what he was doing because like
I said a prostitute was kind of
considered well you paid her so you
could do anything you wanted whether she
wanted you to do it or not you know I
don't think anybody thought anything of
that at the time but the fact that he
was getting prostitutes not only liked
that he was doing things against their
will but he was also getting them to do
blasphemous things yeah and people
weren't that it important and then
exactly that's about it people weren't
that important what was important in
Europe and the 1700s was the church and
nobility yeah they were important yeah
your average person no [ __ ] them and yes
lots of them and they came and went and
they were created by [ __ ] everybody
else was created by magical means yeah
well that's what I mean that's where
they saw a magical stork brought the
magical story well yeah and I and I
definitely do feel like the marquis de
sade as much as he railed against
authority and against the church he was
of a peace with that because he had the
same mentality that they had at the end
of the day because he really felt like
he was better than then he was better
and let other people were beneath him
and they were there as objects so don't
use as he wished so he wasn't as
transgressive as maybe he thought he was
no he was actually kind of playing into
the [ __ ] whole idea of aristocracy
yeah because he used it to his advantage
many times but he I think he knew that
he enjoyed that though he's like [ __ ]
you I'm gonna do it you I'm gonna do
what I want yeah but like you said a lot
a lot of the [ __ ] was that you know he
was justifying [ __ ] that he wanted just
yeah he's trying to justify [ __ ] he was
you know that's the longer you do you
want a sexual [ __ ] offender yeah
that's a sex offender yeah that's what
that's what he was just trying to be
high-minded about that I guess but yeah
so during this time period as I said he
did abuse so many prostitutes that he
got like kind of a bad reputation around
Paris a lot of brothels would not send
him women anymore because of the
reputation that he got because he'd been
reported so many times he did actually
get arrested and imprisoned a few times
like for like minor [ __ ] kind of
sentences over this time period probably
more for the blasphemy [ __ ] than for the
abuse [ __ ] which is sad but that's
probably how it worked out now there
wasn't any really big major deal until
1768
now this is when this is what it's known
as the rose keller affair
now what ended up happening was
apparently Marquis de Sade's strolling
down the street or whatever in Paris and
he comes across this woman named Rose
Keller now some sources say she's a
prostitute although most sources say
that she was just like a widow and she
was like a beggar she was in her 30s
might be the same thing back in those
may be it's like but it she was kind of
like industry she was begging for money
because you know her husband had died
and she didn't have any source of income
anymore um so the Marquis comes across
her and he offers her a job in his house
as a housekeeper right so she needed
money so she said okay now she didn't
agree to be a prostitute or nothing like
that that she was hot too well maybe
yeah she might have I don't know how he
is
yeah although like I said he doesn't
really seem to have any I although he
was like into super young women this he
was I mean I've seen her age anywhere
from thirty to thirty six so she wasn't
like an old woman although probably like
30 36 year-old woman looked a lot older
back then they do nowadays but hard to
say but um I'm not really sure what she
looked like they would have probably
been considered to be a little bit older
than they would be considered to be
today today yeah that's what I'm saying
and um honestly the Mark II when he went
after prostitutes he liked him really
young like thirteen yeah you know well
that was the prime of life in the 17
that's what they thought
12 13 14 you know so apparently he comes
to across this woman who's begging in
the street and he says hey come to my
house I need a housekeeper so she said
okay now when he gets to when she gets
to the house he locks her in a room and
ties her face down on a bed and starts
whipping her and reportedly then pouring
hot wax into the wounds yeah isn't that
nice that's some [ __ ] they would have
done in the 90s though [ __ ] yes goth
girls well like I said but that was all
like consensual that's a sensual this is
not good this is not considered she did
not agree to this [ __ ] she thought she
was just gonna go clean up his [ __ ]
house and all of a sudden now he said
later on that oh I was just
putting pointment on the wind it was and
I'm just like come on no one buys it
give me a [ __ ] break so she was like
tatted now she managed to escape she
gets out of the out of the bindings and
she jumps out like she busts open a like
a second-floor window and jumps out of
the [ __ ] and she goes and like find some
other women like in a bar or something
like that it's like hey there's this
[ __ ] crazy person over there and he
just like coming up and poured hot wax
in my [ __ ] so they went in like reported
this in her [ __ ] shoes for all she
knows this [ __ ] gonna kill you
well that's what I would have said she
don't know wouldn't you assume that you
know how this dude is that's what I mean
yeah I would assume this is a serial
killer and it's like I know that maybe
back then the perception was different
it's like oh well okay this is just what
happens cuz you're a woman back then and
you just get [ __ ] abused and you're
just used to it they didn't know what
BDSM was they didn't so it's like the
fact that you get tied up and whipped
over sudden when you thought you were
just gonna be cleaning this dude's house
yeah and I'd be like yeah I'm out of
here and that's what she did she was
like yeah I'm [ __ ] out of here yeah it
was a surprise session I guess that's
what I mean that's what horrible people
say rape is just surprise surprise
session that's like old what's-his-name
that's cowboy that's we [ __ ] up that
can help with that we know it's [ __ ]
a lawyer
what's it worry we're not saying their
name they always got like some girl with
them well they always have a third yeah
that [ __ ] tries to come up me if
I can try to be all sexy and [ __ ] out I
call him I yeah I say listen a little
Mussolini rub on his head he looks just
like a little mentor Mussolini
well he has called me a nazi and
everything his fascist ass I mean with
his lawyer are you saying you knew I'm
talking about I know you do
yeah you're just kind of like so jealous
of me you think I think he is yeah maybe
so he looks at you he's gets jealous
well yeah anyway I'll just knock that
[ __ ] drunk already
so yes so these poor woman drums
have a good time yeah I'm gonna good
move yeah that's good it's Saturday
night you guys well I know it's not
we're not not when this goes up but we
got a pandemic upon us it's Saturday
night we didn't want to go out we just
wanted to do weird it's a weird time
though with [ __ ] finances and
everything so we decided to stay in and
record the show for you guys right
that's how we do yeah we usually do them
on Saturday nights unless we go out in
which case we try to do them Friday
night so maybe yeah so so this woman
like reports his ass to the authorities
now the family who at this stage his
extended family as well as his wife's
family were not happy about his
shenanigans let's call them that but
there hadn't been anything too egregious
up to this point so they're just kind of
like whatever that's just what those
types of dudes do I guess so what they
did in this case was even though she
reported him to the authorities the
family paid her off so that she would
not testify so they were trying to like
you know keep everything like wraps or
whatever however this incident as well
as another incident later on basically
his mother-in-law you gotta love this
woman his mother-in-law the Madame de
menthe Roy this was one of the incidents
that caused her to basically say [ __ ]
this guy forever and I'm going to spend
the rest of my life trying to get his
stupid ass in prison yeah so and she had
the money to do it the Marquis she was
the more determined the Marquise
collected an arch enemy-- Ephesian or
his nemesis yes she was we hate this
mother wait at it which I couldn't
understand it you know I mean women have
these protective instincts and he was
out there abusing and a [ __ ] gonna have
to take a [ __ ] down well
anything about it only just [ __ ]
around and you have to he was humping
her youngest daughter who was only like
a Tina she was 13 or 14 at the time and
he like took her to like [ __ ] Italy
and [ __ ] like that lately like without
the mothers
but another thing too was that the
Marquise was making her whole family
look bad yeah and she did not like that
not one bit
he's just lucky I wasn't around I don't
have any children but if he was doing
that to my [ __ ] daughter me knowing
him and what he was out I killed that
mother well most people that have
children would have dealt like I said if
you if you hurt my cat I would do
something like that to you so I can
imagine after Pookie your [ __ ] yours I
mean the [ __ ] menu that's what I mean
you were gonna wish you were dead and
when after I'm done with I don't do that
kind of [ __ ] for a living
ain't a joke it's not a joke
that's right she's our child but she's
not a human child sometimes you got to
throw a [ __ ] into the void
yeah there's nothing there and I think
I've mentioned this on the show before
like I said I don't have any human
children but I do have a cat child
OSs and if you did something that I
would not only kill you I would make you
into stew and eat your ass and then she
she I don't understand it I can't
understand it at all I [ __ ] regard
Pookie
yeah guard Pookie I'm watching her she
goes out in the [ __ ] backyard and I'm
keeping an eye over I'm even [ __ ]
looking up for hawks and [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with that cat yeah I don't
know what it is how could human beings
care so much about a damn kitty cat I
just liked I love that cat Eddie to you
well she crawls up on a chest and looks
down at she [ __ ] when you in the night
we're looking at look at these [ __ ]
crazy ass eyes well she she likes to in
the middle of it because she usually
sleeps by me she usually sleep by my leg
or like up by my elbow like in my armpit
or something she likes to do that but if
she's out running around in the night
it's like every now and then like every
couple hours I think she likes to come
up and check yeah to see if we're all
right or see what we're doing so every
now and then like it'll be three o'clock
in the morning and I'll be a little
female and then her little face will be
like right there like through the
blanket through their big old beady eyes
and she'll be like what are you are you
there are you all right
I watched a dance I watched a damn
elephant paint a picture of another
elephant with her with a foot I was
impressed as [ __ ] elephants are very
intelligent yeah they even have like
yeah they even have like elephants image
like they mourn their dead and
everything and eyes are way smarter than
we give them credit but I think about
that as a human you know I mean we're
very human centric over - over time I've
kind of realized that there are certain
animals that are gifted elephants cats
dogs yeah you know they're well I'm like
I said of pretty much anyone that's had
a passion for Andes monks amount of time
we'll understand and I'm I used to think
it was just some kind of a kind of a an
AI or a mechanical thing you know what I
mean like huh or they can't just love
you because you feed them yeah no I
don't think no no that's the case yeah
well and honestly I was just more like
it's more like the consciousness of a
child yeah I was just reading a study
the other day that they had done Studies
on cats because people have a perception
that cats are not as lovable or is human
centric as dogs are like not as about
humans um but I don't think that's true
at all I mean it depends on the cat
obviously but a human will choose human
companionship over yeah I can't well
they've showed that most cats will
choose human companionship over food or
toys or anything else you know not all
of them obviously but like I said
they're just like people they have
different personalities because we have
two cats and one of our cats is very
aloof yeah like she'll hang out with you
sometimes like if she's lonely but then
she's like [ __ ] off whatever I don't
like really care and she'll kind of go
spend time by herself
but baby cookie is not like that at all
she is very much like always wanting to
be talked about the cat like it's a
child it wonder stand it she wants to be
involved in like everything you're doing
it's like oh hey you doing laundry can I
help you chilly let me sit on the towels
I'm going to help you out we've got a
lot of people in the audience so you
know they have animals you know we have
animals to understand it I mean they're
part of your family for those of you who
are not regulars to the show I'm not I'm
not that much of a softie really you
know I mean I'm fine I'm an ex-soldier
or I even [ __ ] hunted a lot killed a
lot of deer a lot of rabbits killer
squirrels there's certain animals that
are very special and yeah I think it's
luck do the selective breeding and just
the way they are some animals or pets
other animals like elephants or they
just they just have a very good
consciousness and you know monkeys and
chimpanzees or monkeys and great apes
you know I mean they're they're they're
sophisticated I see them these are
respect for them I got respectful I see
them basically the same way you would
see like a human child yeah they're all
on the realm of intellectually they're
pretty much yeah they're about like on a
level of a child
yeah but a child could be bad but then
so these animals can be bad too is you
know some animals don't you know like
it's not it's a continuum it's not like
Oh animals are different than humans
they're not they're not well they don't
have the same abilities no but they have
a lot of the same emotions and a lot of
think what we're talking about is that
there are some animals that have
consciousness they ask they de are
self-aware yeah many of them are yeah
and I think our cat is one of those yeah
they know what they are they know how
they feel because I think she thinks
she's a person yeah she definitely comes
across like she thinks she's it's funny
tiny fuzzy Bert it's not and it's not
paranormal or anything it's just this
well like I said because I've had other
cats before and I didn't feel that way
about them but the you know certain cats
are you know even though I love cats
yeah in general but some cats are very
aware he's the first one that seemed
like like a person person yeah you know
what I mean like interacted like a
virgin I would agree yeah so um so as I
was saying so the Marquis mother-in-law
essentially was like after this whole
[ __ ] happened with Rose Keller and
you're like you know ruining my family
name or whatever she was like all right
I'm gonna get this [ __ ] so what she
ended up doing she goes to the king and
she gets what is called a lettre de
cachet which essentially that's my
remember my French colonel is hidden
letter or secret letter that is
basically a thing where the king is
saying that you can get arrested and
imprisoned without access to courts so
it's kind of like a workaround like
whenever we catch your dumb ass we're
just gonna throw you in jail you're not
gonna have a trial or anything like that
so she got one of those against him
so at this stage so it's it kind of goes
on for a few years where he's kind of
like running away he kind of like ran to
Italy for a while like to kind of lay
low and whatever now four years later in
1772 this is when we're talking about
his Manzo right now he had a man servant
named Latour yeah and a hold on
70 70 1772 in the United States you know
what's happening around this time it's
kind of weird when you think about it
yeah yeah a few more years ago to
declare independence from England and
there's there's the brewing insurgency
going on and a lot of it and a lot of
the ideas from it came Jim you know
French revolutionary right and there's
things like that French writing and that
went terribly wrong but French
enlightenment writing is now [ __ ]
influenced again look an American
colonists you got [ __ ] said you
got badasses like Franklin and Benjamin
Franklin you know they laughed at him in
England but very modern guy you know he
wasn't a lot of very modern living in
sin with [ __ ] his girlfriend and
living the life of a modern dude now you
know you read up on Franklin Franklin
was a [ __ ] cool [ __ ] he's
very cool taking air baths using nudists
yeah he liked young women he liked he
liked but at least everybody Newt like I
don't I don't think he raped anybody no
no raping everything is about liberty
and freedom of jealousy I mean I feel
like all the chicks that hung out with
him were like yeah - yeah and evidently
that's fine
evidently in France and the United
States oh the French love depends they
[ __ ] love that digit and it was
Coonskin cap dude had gay dude had game
even though he wasn't a good-looking
dude now it's like how to play it he was
just like worked it that just goes to
show it doesn't really matter what you
look like no it's all it's it's it's
you're in your internal spirit it's your
aura man you're and he was okay Franklin
was the first American celebrity yeah
international celebrity I would say Ben
Franklin the Coonskin cap [ __ ] was his
[ __ ] was [ __ ] he knew that that
was some [ __ ] hokey American career
so he didn't everybody would like fixate
because they don't have it they don't
have it I think it was exotic right dude
[ __ ] dude scored a lot of trim
evidently that's what I've heard
yeah score laughter I don't know how
much of it was just him bragging or
other people bragging for the French
said he was [ __ ] tearing it up so
okay that's that's the source and that's
kind of a French thing the French said
that he was tearing it up at the court
there because he understood and is
playing French courtesan games yeah in
France and like I said this is another
thing that makes me think that the
Marquis de Sade's just the worst because
if the French are condemning you yeah
then it must be bad there's a problem
because the French are all about that
[ __ ] he was violating Liberty though
that's what I mean that's like that's
what I mean and that's the line that I
have to cross look I said I'm you know
he was taking freedom from others yeah
say how free can a free society be a
free society can be as free as it can be
but it's not free to take freedom from
others yeah you can't be without a due
process yeah and a due process in
American terms means it has to be a
serious process in a court to find out
if you've committed some kind of crime
and then they take your your Liberty
yeah and I mean I get like I said that's
why I don't I don't agree that the
Marquis de Sade's writings or anything
like that should be banned because
that's just writing however is what
actions right yes or what because
obviously he was taking advantage of
people for his own ends
yeah well and that is always wrong that
goes back to the mayor to the American
values of the [ __ ] of the First
Amendment you're free to say and to
create whatever you want and all yeah
but you can't do it yeah don't do it
because that might actually take Liberty
from another firm another person
everything has to be consensual that's
not the First Amendment assault that's
why it's like you know make all the porn
you want as long as everyone in it is
okay as long as it's not child porn as
long as you're not making a snuff film
and right
like do whatever you want like people
have consent yeah like people can watch
it or not right but I think that people
should be able to make that decision for
themselves I don't think movies should
be caught or run okay [ __ ] man or
anything like that man you know I don't
care what Epstein says there are certain
people that can't give consent exactly
they're too young
yeah and we all agreed up to a certain
age and like I said you could argue
about what that age is you could argue
if it's 18 you could argue if it's 16
you could argue like other things but
obviously a child right is not the same
as an adult
obviously in Mississippi according to
the last law I read it consent was 14
that was a little bit old school that's
what I mean that's or teen is a little
that's young 14 was the age of consent
last time I think an argument could be
made for 16 although I'm uncomfortable
with that but I think 16 in
Mississippi's when they could get
married and be wouldn't get married at
in Florida at 16 - all that well I don't
know if the law has changed recent road
but that's what it was la cerva me a lot
of those laws are so old they haven't
really been challenged because most
people because most people don't it's
not something it's not coming up think
about right it's not come yeah because
most people nowadays don't get married
till then they're tomorrow 2:30 so it's
like it doesn't really come out but yeah
14 I'm uncomfortable with that I'm a
little uncomfortable with 16 although an
argument could be made for 16 I think
dad's have agreed I think 18 is a good
the fans have a green that 18 is the
time in which which a girl can give
consent to do porn
yeah and I'm alright with that yeah
that's about right
I mean that seems about that's right
yeah you're still kind you're still
pretty young and if you go to war and a
teen is a man then you can decide you
good yes seriously so if you're gonna
make porn 18 you're gonna be you should
make everything 18 drinking age
everything that should just be 18
because we've just decided that that's
what adulthood is and that seems like a
good age I think the the Mississippi 14
year old consent thing I think what
they're talking about is the I have the
high school age yeah is that it's not
rape but I think they're talking about
other people around that time
that age see that's another now I don't
think they're taking in account
statutory yes see that's a different
thing though because like like I said 14
year-olds are having sex yeah I don't
think he's your prosecutor oh they're
one of those because that's not they're
both 14 year olds man I was I was 13 12
13 lusting after girls that age that's
what I mean a lot of people like a lot
of teenagers have said and like I you
know I'm new teenage that had sex with
13 14 15 it's like as long as you're
having sex with some of the same age or
I'd be a year two older some states want
to pull that statutory thing well
there's too much of an age difference
between you two but that's a
sophisticated concept when you think
about it yeah it's gonna take you back
in the seventeen and eighteen hundred's
that are making these rules aren't
thinking along those lines well no they
wouldn't because they were going women
he's 35 you shouldn't be long married at
35 yeah you got I mean so that's why
that wasn't there in the law well and
back in the day it wasn't that weird for
say a 28-year old man to marry a 12 or
13 year old girl like no one thought
that well that's because that's a 28
year old it took 28 years to get the
wealth you needed to marry anybody and
they figured hey she only just had her
period so now she can have as many
babies well the only me unmarried women
that were available for a 28 year old
would have been pretty young yeah
because all youth they were all long
married yeah so it's all depends on like
I said it's meh solution but I can see
how it happened back then but it's
there's no excuse for it nowadays
obvious not because it's situation yeah
it's because society is not the same and
like I said it's wasn't cool back then
but you can understand how it happened
they didn't know they didn't know any
better they didn't know what cool was
back then no they didn't the situation
was very different yeah yeah so so there
there there was very few cool by the
[ __ ] I think back then ya know and
then I'll read something from like back
in like this 17th or 18th century and
I'll be like wow that sounds like really
modern but it's very very rare yeah a
lot of times I'll read some back then
I'm like what the [ __ ] are they talking
yeah what are they talking about what is
it well hey oh that's okay there's a
pokey oh my goodness she just came in
she wants to come in all by herself yeah
so yeah so let's go back to 1772 so now
this other incident that got him into
hot water so he had a manservant as you
mentioned named
Latour no heat okay they go to mur same
yeah and he says to Latura go out and
find me some prostitutes I like him
quote unquote very young and he's
talking like 12 13 years old like just
you know tweens yeah but back in those
days they were walking around selling it
I guess so people didn't live as long
and so he gets so Latour arounds up for
prostitutes and brings them back to this
Chateau that they're staying at now one
thing that Marquis does that had he had
this like really fancy like Crystal box
and it had these really really nice like
high-end chocolates in there now at this
particular session let's call it that
sources differ over whether the Marquis
gave the chocolates to the prostitutes
or whether they just kind of helped
themselves to the choc because they were
like hey chocolate you know free
chocolate and it was in just in the box
and they ate it now the problem being
that unbeknownst to them the chocolates
had been soaked in Spanish Y which if
you've seen any 80s sex comedy you know
it was like it was kind of like touted
as like an aphrodisiac which I guess you
could call it but the reason that it was
used in an aphrodisiac one if you eat it
it will make you violently sick and may
put you in a coma and maybe die but I
think the reason that it was touted as
an aphrodisiac was because one of the
side effects of what the chemical does
is that it makes your it swells your
urethra so in women it doesn't like get
you hot or anything it's just like ow
I'm in horrible pain I'm vomiting and it
hurts to pee but in men it gives you a
horrible like like an erection but a
really painful erection
may not go away without medical
intervention yeah so what ended up
happening here was that these poor women
like ate these chocolates not knowing
that they had Spanish Y in them and two
of them got violently ill um you know
vomiting and everything like that and
they thought that they had been poisoned
which they kind of had what is this in
her it's um it's kind of like I can't
remember the name of the chemical but it
comes from like it is the same chemical
that they call it Spanish Fly because it
does actually come from like an insect
that's called like a Spanish Fly but
it's mixed with something else and I
can't remember what it is offhand but
it's this particular chemical that
causes the reaction but it's not an
aphrodisiac they just thought it was not
in that sense it it's considered that
like I said it got that reputation
because it swells your urethra that's
why but not in a fun way
yeah so what made them think that would
turn the [ __ ] on I can't
understand no but so yeah so at least
two of the women like that ate the
chocolates got violently ill and were
afraid they had been poisoned now they
actually went and reported the [ __ ] to
the police they also reported that
Marquis de Sade engaged in sodomy with
his manservant litter like I said he
didn't really care about man woman child
anything he would just like [ __ ]
anything that moved
yeah man servants just [ __ ] take him
up in a bootie and it [ __ ] Harvey -
yeah both wait it's like top bottom he
didn't care like I said he was just like
any it was all it was all it was a
sexual buffet and he was like at an
all-you-can-eat sexual my favorite yeah
he didn't care if it was given receiving
it was a [ __ ] trip and not
necessarily in a good way either you
know I mean I know I ain't I'm not down
with it that's really it like I said
it's like it just it bothers me so much
because it sounds like you're being like
sex negative and stuff like that which
I'm not because like I said if anything
you want to get up to in your privacy of
your own home with other consenting
adults you just knock yourself out too
much [ __ ] that god-sent
that's what I mean it's just so much of
the [ __ ] hinged upon them kidnapping
people or paying people and then
you know reminds me - it just reminds me
too much a [ __ ] Albert Fish yeah so
so these two so marquita sodden Latour
get you know they don't get arrested
because they [ __ ] ran off to Italy
because they knew they were gonna get in
trouble the authorities sentenced them
to death in absentia damn and burned
them in effigy
which though it seems like a waste of
time it's like they're not even here but
we're mad and we have to do so the death
oh man I've run they did well they did
they went to Italy yeah now um another
thing that did not endear the marquis de
sade his mother-in-law was the fact that
he took the young his wife's and her
sister what an inlet or took off to
Italy took her with them and so yeah the
mother-in-law was again not very happy
about that either why she was wonder
what she thought of all this no like I
said she thought that she was excited
she was very young so I'm not really
sure if she even knew that she could do
anything cuz it's weird because I feel
like he probably used his magic on her
maybe he's talking to her and like yeah
he may be I mean like I said she was
very young
yeah though he might have been like all
like sweet-talking her and [ __ ] she was
like oh he loves me and all this other
kind of [ __ ] like some [ __ ] where he's
twisting it around about you yeah like
where well we got him where where where
up ending Society this is important yeah
he probably gave her some [ __ ] noise
like we don't listen to any any young
girls out there don't listen to any
[ __ ] that lady I'm sure he was doing
all kinds of [ __ ] any [ __ ] we're
going where no man has gone before we're
changing the world you know some [ __ ]
like that
he didn't he does seem like he thought
that yeah he was like an edge Lord
before so yeah so they run off to Italy
they got caught like on the way and like
imprisoned in a fortress for a little
while but they escaped because
apparently the security was a not very
lakhs so this what earth was very lacks
yeah well they he did that a couple
well they probably thought well they're
noblemen they won't they won't escape
their honor
damn honor yes they have honor and
there's like right here in this
courtyard
we'll call you back into prison and so
he ends up coming back to France and
going to his family Chateau at Lacoste
the Chateau de Lacoste
yeah yeah which is still there although
it's a ruin now it is but it's probably
ball one right yeah yeah yeah I figured
well I just said that yeah well what you
don't realize good usually just wasted
yeah so he goes back to Lacoste and his
wife is still there his [ __ ] wife I
don't know man there must been something
wrong with her to it she would like put
up with a bunch of [ __ ] I don't know if
she was into it too or she just thought
she can do anything about it or what I
don't know what her deal was buddy
Marquis must has a big old dick to get
away with some [ __ ] I don't know if he
did or not it's like did anybody even
say what the [ __ ] I mean you would think
that you'd if he didn't have a big dick
it's like that a [ __ ] must have
a [ __ ] 10-inch [ __ ] dick to get
rid of this [ __ ]
God you don't I don't know man
understandeth even a 10-inch dick wait
it wouldn't be enough 30 would be enough
though right no okay over a certain size
it just becomes yeah then because of
pain yeah yeah there becomes an
impediment but yeah so he goes back to
Lacoste and his wife is still there and
apparently at this point his wife starts
either joining in the festivities or was
at least okay with it because she didn't
report anything I've got a feeling that
they join in maybe she was like in on it
well it's weird because it talked oh you
could probably back in those days kind
of [ __ ] finesse a woman in this show
well yeah and I was just gonna say that
earlier is that back in those days I
feel like a lot of women particularly
married women I don't know if they even
had like the concept that you could be
like not alike that right don't do that
yeah you know what I mean it's maybe
they didn't have that kind of they just
like well they just do with that's what
they do and you just have to deal with
it yeah
but I would be interested to get into my
[ __ ] time machine I would be too
because I'd like to see how much of that
[ __ ] my [ __ ] DeLorean and go back in
time because I can see the way these
people were because I kind of feel like
yeah culture makes a big difference but
in a way - it's like human nature being
what it is and since women have always
been just as stubborn and just as you
know just like men are so I always kind
of feel like there had to be some
resentment caster she's not that she's
behind my chair like tearing up the
chair she likes to like claw like under
the gym and she goes all the way around
like a merry-go-round yeah he slays on
her back and she's tearing [ __ ] up she's
hilarious yeah she's funny I don't know
she's making all kind of noise back
there but yeah um so I kind of wonder
how much resentment there was with women
of the time period that were just like
you just had to like put up with all
this [ __ ] that the dudes were doing
you know what I mean it's like what
could they do anything about it
probably they have any recourse probably
I don't know women always have a way of
getting even with you I think I think a
lot we are very David yeah I think a lot
of [ __ ]
devious we're just we're I think um I
think women had a lot more power than
they do it [ __ ] crazy come here daddy
yeah yeah um women are a lot more pop I
think throughout history we're a lot
more powerful
there are lots meteor and devious
[ __ ] and we can do and we're
like in a lonely how to reliable a
smarter gossipy manipulating [ __ ]
will [ __ ] ditch it true
we have other we have other avenues
dependent I wish you would have to
because if you are generally not as
physically strong or large have to play
another you have to do something else
look man I'm gonna tell you something
straight up when you
read the oldest of human history you
start going back into the Old Testament
and all these old all this stuff is
really designed to kinda negate women's
power gentlemen its paternalistic that's
why I always thought that it was because
it must have been a backlash it must
have been that women ran the [ __ ] they
were afraid of us yeah I think women ran
the show in prehistory and that I think
it was like a revolt that's what I mean
I think it all comes down to like all of
the laws that have been made throughout
history to take away women's um you know
autonomy or take away wins power stuff
like that is because what happened in
its well I think it's because of fear
it's it's because of either they're
afraid of what women have done or what
they can do right I think it's what they
have done that's what I think you know I
gotta think that in prehistory
they were maternal istic societies
that's what I think our pain you don't
talk about where matriarchal yeah I
think that was actually the beginning of
it a lot of the old [ __ ] was actually
goddesses big fat goddesses the
goaltender I think I think there was it
makes more sense to maybe get worse is
that because women are the ones that
create that create other and I think I
think it sometime in prehistory women
were actually worshipped as some kind of
goddesses and then those days then that
they ran his show I kind of think that
men revolted from that be on the show
hey Pookie okay you be a bad girl
yeah she's being bad yeah she she teared
up all the time it was like I have like
Christmas and Valentine's Day like right
over there and she's just like that's
her favorite thing she loves paper yeah
so yeah so he goes back to Lacoste his
wife is there and she's apparently like
either down with it or like lalalala
looking the other way so during this
time period uh Marquis de Sade has like
a whole bunch of quote-unquote employees
at the Chateau many of whom are young
teenage girls or boys and most of them
ended up complaining that they had like
raped or molested them at some point and
ended up like fleeing the [ __ ] place
and terror so during this so he gets a
reputation again ends up having to flee
to Italy again 1776 he comes back to
Lacoste hires a bunch of servant girls
they also took off terrified because he
couldn't keep his [ __ ] hands off them
apparently and in 1777 one of the girls
that he had employed that had taken off
that girl's dad came to the house and
shot the Marquis in the face or tried to
but the gun misfired ooh
so he escaped death yeah so like I said
this is not a popular [ __ ]
people are coming to his house trying to
like shoot him in the face because of
all the [ __ ] that he's doing to their
children so you know I don't blame him
I don't either I have to tell you so
later that same year which was 1776 um
Marit the Marquis de Sade it's tricked
into coming back to Paris because
Lacoste his house was kind of like out
in the boondocks not nowadays but it
back in the old days when he was alive
it was kind of out in the middle of
nowhere so in some ways it was kind of
like a thing where he you know it was so
remote that he could like get away with
a lot of [ __ ] out there because it was
kind of like it was out like outside the
city so he gets tricked into going back
to Paris and I think maybe his
mother-in-law might have been behind
some of the [ __ ] they told him it's like
hey your mom is like really sick you
need to come see her so the Mark II
decided that what he did not know was
that his mother was already dead so he
comes back to him in a way I kind of
hoped that his mother-in-law did that
cuz that's really mean and I love that
but it's like come on [ __ ] yeah your
poor mom sick oh [ __ ] you she's already
dead so yes so um so he gets back to
Paris and then he gets he already had
like a death sentence hanging over said
from before remember cuz they had like
burned him in absentia so he still had
that outstanding charge so he gets to
Paris and
arrest him and they imprison him in the
chateau de vincennes I guess that's how
you pronounce it now he did get he did
appeal the death sentence in 1778 so he
got that overturned but since he still
had that the Kings like a letter de
cachet like the thing that said hey
you're going to jail no matter you don't
get a trial or anything so they still
like pulled that at their ass and said
okay well and then they just throw him
in prison so he escaped from there again
but they recaptured him again he while
he was in prison he also like made
friends with this other guy who was a
Count de Mirabeau who was also like into
like writing pornography and was into
all that kind of [ __ ] so they kind of
like hung out for a little while but
then they ended up like hating each
other the way some people who were like
really similar I guess sometimes maybe
gotten to they like [ __ ] the
consensual action it's like you're doing
it against people so maybe that's what I
don't know what they were arguing about
but for some reason they ended up like
hating each other like lifelong animes
so this particular prison that he was in
ended up closing in 1784 so then he gets
transferred to the bus steel now while
he's in the bus steel you know he was
like really bored and he was really
really whiny about having to be you know
imprisoned because it was such a big
inconvenience and everything because of
his revolutionary ideas in blah-dee-blah
he was like one of those type of dudes
he was always like complaining about
that kind of [ __ ] so he as an outlet for
his frustration he started writing now
very famously in the Bastille in 1784 he
wrote the manuscript for what would
become probably one of his most famous
books the 120 days of sodom so also very
famously the 120 days of Sodom was
written because they would not give him
any paper or pens because they you know
know what kind of [ __ ] he was up to so
he would just find like kind of scraps
of paper and he wrote the whole book
which as I said was never really
finished it was just kind of like you
know the the introduction of the first
part were finished and the rest of it
was just like really detailed notes he
wrote it on like little bits of paper
which he taped together and then like he
kind of rolled up on like this cotton
spool like a like a toilet paper and
then he would like stuff it in this
little hidey hole in the wall now when
they ended up finding this [ __ ] it was
like and you can still see the [ __ ]
the original manuscript board is 39 feet
long and it's just on this little
[ __ ] like a toilet paper spool and
the writing is so small that to read it
you need a magnifying glass wonder how
he wrote it that's what I mean it's like
yeah I don't know how it's [ __ ] yet
so he wrote this [ __ ] now he was
apparently he was working on this and he
didn't finish it he had all the notes
and everything now on the fourth of July
1789 he got transferred to an insane
asylum as Cheryl and Tom now he had been
one of the reasons why he got
transferred to an insane asylum for the
best deal was because this was of course
like right before the outbreak of the
you know the worst outbreak the French
Revolution and so he had been like there
was all these moms like rioting and
she'll like that like outside the best
deal and he would like he had made this
like little kind of like handmade like
little megaphone and he was like
inciting like all the rioters outside
he's like hey they're killing us in here
they're slitting a slitting our throats
storm the bus deals on the best so he
was like yelling at them out the window
so so they apparently took him he was
like naked and everything and they they
transferred him to Cheryl tall which was
an insane asylum now this was ten days
before mobs actually did storm the
Bastille now since his manuscript for
120 days of Sodom was he thought still
in the wall of his cell he thought that
when the bastille cut stormed by the
mobs of you know angry people that it
was lost forever and he was really
really sad about it because he apparent
he'd put like a lot of work into this is
probably still there the wall wouldn't
know what end up happening this is so
weird this is like one of history's
mysteries okay two days before the best
deal was stormed for some reason I'm not
really sure why this random
dude and all they know about him is his
name his name was our node to st.
Maximus and he for some reason went into
the Marquis cell and found the
manuscript and took it so he saved it
but the Marquis didn't know that so he
died thinking that that manuscript had
been destroyed in the storming of the
Bastille for whatever and they don't
know why the guy took it they don't know
how the guy knew it was in there they
don't know anything about this dude
other than his name what'd he do with it
he later took it and he likes sold it to
various collect collectors and you know
it ended up getting published later on
but not until like it wasn't widely
published until the early 20th century
actually so he made a buck off of it not
much though because it was only during
the 19th century his writings were not
really all that known and really only
like some underground it was kind of
like oh some of your enlightenment
writers and like you know you know
writers like flow bear and stuff like
that like gustav lu bear like they knew
about it so it was kind of like on the
dl it was kind of like with the cool
kids you about they read writings yeah
it was like it was just like real small
press [ __ ] because they knew that if
they published it like if a real
publishing house publisher you'd get in
[ __ ] trouble
I didn't bother I see you couldn't
publish it they couldn't even [ __ ]
make never mind the bollocks the [ __ ]
Sex Pistols album without getting in
trouble yeah which is crazy and if you
read this [ __ ] this is like it's a
billion times worse so yeah it's it's
just like weird why this guy like took
it but like I said he he did like he
passed it to like collectors and
booksellers and stuff like that who
later under like small press and they
kind of circulated it among you know
various like circles of like free
thinkers and things like that but it
didn't really get any wide circulation
till early 20th century so later on like
after kind of the French Revolution
starts taking hold
they actually abolished the whole like
hit kings hidden letter thing like where
people could just be arrested and
detained without any trial they got rid
of that his wife ended up divorcing him
around this time now
weirdly as okay so he had published a
bunch of his books like
anonymously like he wouldn't even put
his name on him or anything so this is
around 1790 now he's you know kind of
like free at this point for a little
while like cuz he kind of got out of the
insane asylum for a bit so during the
time that he was free briefly he met
this actress who or had formerly been an
actress her name was Marie Constance she
already had a six-year-old son she was a
widow I believe and he was him and her
were kind of like together until the end
although he was still like [ __ ]
around because it was the Marquis de
Sade you know you're talking about the
weird thing was that even though he was
an aristocrat and obviously you know
when the French Revolution happened and
the new kind of regime came in they did
not look too kindly on the aristocracy
and in fact cut a bunch of their heads
off you know as most people will know
however the Marquis de Sade's able to
kind of like wangle his way into their
midst by saying hey the aristocracy
[ __ ] me over too because I'm a free
thinker and they wouldn't let me publish
all my stuff and I've been in jail and I
was in trouble and everything like that
and they kind of bought that so and he
even like did the whole thing where he
like changed his name to like citizens
citizens Assad did all this other kind
of stuff so it's like he kind of
endeared himself to them a little bit
and they even like gave him some kind of
higher up positions and [ __ ] like that
he's just playing [ __ ] witch yeah I
think he was just trying to save his own
he's using his known no ability to get
ass yeah that's enough suck ass over
yeah back in the day yeah he's [ __ ]
yeah he's full of [ __ ]
yeah I understand it that so he's just
trying to do he can do that's what I
mean he was just trying to save his own
butt yeah you don't care about any cause
or no like that so now apparently he
goes back to his like chateau and
Lacoste but as with many um aristocratic
like properties at the time the
revolutionaries had looted them or
destroyed them or whatever so it had
kind of been like destroyed and like I
said it still stands today but it's
essentially a ruin so he goes and moves
back to Paris now in 1790 he gets
elected to the National
convention and he actually wrote like a
whole bunch of like political pamphlets
and stuff and he advocated like for some
you know [ __ ] that the revolutionaries
were trying to get like a direct vote
and you know various other things but a
lot of the revolutionaries still like
kind of looked askance at him because
you know he was still essentially an
aristocrat also his son actually was in
the military and he deserted and so he
had to kind of distance himself from
that because it was kind of like yes so
that was kind of like the thing he was
not a patriot right so it kind of looked
like that
so there was kind of a lot of [ __ ] going
on there now he also kind of got in
trouble like during the reign of terror
in 1793 he wrote a eulogy for jean-paul
Marat in which he was kind of like very
law to Tory toward him which a lot again
a lot of people looked askance at he
also was critical of Robespierre who had
taken over at the time so he kind of got
in trouble for that yeah but you know
okay for any of the American audience
you got to understand that the French
Revolution was very different from the
American Revolution
if you were to look at the French
Revolution than the jacobins the
Jacobins were [ __ ] [ __ ] to the
Jacobins were [ __ ] communist
basically they kill you in a [ __ ]
heartbeat well there were no good guys
in the eduation really you couldn't
[ __ ] somebody ideas were good but in
practice it didn't not so good now your
acid via the guillotine before you
[ __ ] knew it
the French Revolution was not really a
good thing no like I said yes the ideals
behind it were good yeah but in tactus
it wasn't terrorism and in practice it
didn't jail and then the only thing that
ended it would have been [ __ ] Napoleon
Bonaparte it was although it should be
said that after Napoleon came in he
didn't like the Marquis either no
Napoleon would in American terminology
you could say
Napoleon was a Republican a secular
Republican who thought he was God it was
a weird [ __ ] thing I'm not sure
there's an American analogy although you
don't think any politicians don't think
they're God come on no I think I oh I'd
rather I'd rather [ __ ] have Napoleon
as a commander than the city then
Robespierre rose Pierre we couldn't be
trusted he was kind of tipped like I
said everyone's terrible yeah yeah the
situation's right at the drop of a hat
rose chair puts you underneath the
guillotine at least at least [ __ ] it at
least Napoleon had an understandable ego
yeah I can you could predict him you
could predict you know it's a crazy
position though it's that when when um
the Marquis de Sade was still like in
okay like in good graces like with the
revolutionaries yeah he was actually his
father and mother-in-law the
mother-in-law who hated him so much they
were actually in line to go to the
guillotine and he stepped in on their
behalf and like saved their asses that's
something else wait a minute well I
guess almost out of character from what
I'm I think he did it just so he'd have
something to hold it yeah maybe I mean
it seems like it seems magnanimous but I
don't think he did it for those reasons
either that or maybe [ __ ] the Marquis
was just like these [ __ ] are
crazy I mean it was a complicated
individual but I do feel like his
overriding philosophy was
self-preservation so I do feel like and
they were the ones with the money yeah I
mean he did ask them for money
even though they hated him and we're
trying to like destroy him at every turn
but he did save them from the guillotine
but like I said I don't think he did it
out of any like humanistic that's hard
to say I don't think he did I mean it
would it would be out of character if he
did it just because he was a nice guy I
don't think he was I'm just gonna say to
the audience based upon everything that
I've
red you could not trust jacobins they
would [ __ ] turn on you they would
turn on you and they'd [ __ ] send you
the guillotine didn't matter what you
believed and it was more like trial by
gossip at any one moment they could say
you're a [ __ ] enemy of the revolution
and [ __ ] cut your head off over the
slightest things at least Napoleon was a
[ __ ] predictable autocrat I guess you
could call him it was a predictable
Emperor I'm gonna - I'd probably take
that I would definitely take Napoleon
anyway he wasn't short either that's a
suicide he was trapped tight he was
average height you know actually a
little bit above average height that was
British propaganda that said he was
short he was Napoleon was trying to save
the situation although he was also a
mortal man you know I mean he had
weaknesses well like I said there's no
there's no good guy there's no good guys
in this situation no not there aren't
very many good guys in history a lot a
lot of it no that's because good guys
you don't hear about you don't hear
about them [ __ ] it you don't hear about
gay pretty much all usually all great
men if you were to kind of quantify them
on a more on a moral level all great men
are kind of bad if you're not bad you're
never gonna be great well no one's gonna
remember that one's gonna remember not
too much great as in oh there's no
awesome it's just no one's gonna
remember it's more about who's strong
and who's weak more than anything else
although there's some strong
[ __ ] that I like dude I mean
I'm just I mean there was some deadly
[ __ ] that I liked I mean you
know there's something about Genghis
Khan that kind of [ __ ] well I think
many people even though people don't
condone some of these people's actions
there's a reason I mean people there's
just time and a place for everything
it's why people are fascinated by serial
killers is why people still remember
Vlad the Impaler you know [ __ ]
Countess báthory or than that one shows
about because people are just fascinated
by that kind of stuff and I think in a
way it's good to be fascinated by that
kind of stuff because the fact that
we're fascinated by it means that it's
not all that
common yeah in some ways which is good
because we don't need a whole bunch of
Vlad the Impaler if I were to pick one
of them out of history though if I were
to pick one man out of history that I
would say I would respect that mother
that would have to be Julius yeah I just
[ __ ] likes Julius Julius was a man of
his time he understood the [ __ ]
beauty of a shorn body liked a hairless
body he'll he was a military man who had
style and he he crossed that Rubicon the
die was cast he made the move that he
had to make but unfortunately [ __ ]
people of the Roman Republic could not
handle his greatness
sometimes a [ __ ] too much of a
man for other men I guess what they did
to him what they did a Jew is they paid
though they paid for what they did to
him yeah a good Augustus [ __ ] his
heir took vengeance and became the
[ __ ] first emperor of Rome and you
know that's the thing that [ __ ]
Westerners that's a time it's a time in
which Westerners should all [ __ ]
study because that dramas playing out
even today in the Western world I'm
gonna leave it at that I'm leaving today
I just I've read I read Julius and
[ __ ] azzam as his fellow military man
I understand his predilections I could
appreciate it yeah yeah
so alright didn't mean to distract it
yes yeah you're coming yeah yeah no it's
just I was manic crushing on an ancient
man yeah I guess so as I said so because
um because Marquis de Sade was a
critical of Robespierre he actually got
fired from all his posts and he got
thrown into prison again for a year he
was let out in 1794 after the reign of
terror had ended now in 1796 at this
point he's pretty much broke ass he
celled he sold his castle or
chateau and Lacoste which you know was a
ruin but he was able to get a couple
bucks for it I guess but he didn't
really have all that much money he ended
up like living in the back of a barn or
some [ __ ] like that
so 1801 after Napoleon has come to power
after the reign of terror now I feel
like the Marquis was kind of thinking oh
well now it's a new regime and I'll just
like you know suck up to that one as
well just like he usually did however
Napoleon pretty much didn't want any of
the Marquis [ __ ] he was just kind of
like the two books that had come out
Justine and Juliet which had been
published anonymously he basically said
whoever wrote those books I want that
[ __ ] arrested so what they did was the
official means you read them yeah well I
think a lot of people read yeah okay so
basically they had kind of likes yeah
yeah they had those Katie yeah yeah so
they had basically they had somebody
like stake out the publishing house
waiting for someone to show up you know
with a with you know some [ __ ] that
would like prove that they had written
it unfortunately for the Marquis he did
actually show up at the publishing house
and he cover so he gets sent to this one
prison and so while he's at this one
prison he gets accused of seducing other
prisoners there because like I said who
are we talking about here you can't take
him anywhere obviously so then he gets
transferred to another prison like a
much worse one now his family at this
stage they kind of intervene and they're
kind of like hey why don't you because
the prison that he was transferred to
was apparently really bad like really
violent so they said why don't you send
it to a nice insane asylum so they ended
up sending him back to Cheryl's off in
1803 now his by this point ex-wife
because she had obtained it of divorce
and his children he had three of them
and they were grown by this point they
said that they would pay for him to stay
there
now even though this was an insane
asylum
it didn't seem like he was suffering too
much I mean they let like his mistress
apparently the Marquis told the you know
the insane asylum officials or whatever
that his mistress was a relative so they
let her live like in the room next to
his so he had access to his mistress all
the time they also let him have all of
his 600 books they let him have paper
and pens and whatever else he wanted in
fact the abbot that ran the place was
kind of progressive in his views he was
kind of like an early advocate and that
you know he got a lot of flack for this
but he was an early advocate for
patients and insane asylums having like
creative outlets so he kind of
encouraged the Marquis to write he also
liked some of the Marquis plays that he
wrote he would let the Marquis like put
the plays on in the insane asylum with
the other patients like as actors and
like they would like like people would
come and see them well it sounds like
the Marquis made a fan if I guess yeah
you know back before you know VHS and
DVD and blue-ray you might want to
[ __ ] see a play and you know if you
were if you were a religious fit you
know minor religious figure you might
want to watch it basically like watching
a movie from yeah they didn't have me
put on a play you know you want to see
that I could understand it yeah because
it would be kind of like a [ __ ] it
would become like a delicacy wouldn't it
yeah be something was kind of [ __ ]
only certain people could see and that
maybe when some crazy [ __ ] like hey
looks good in the insane asylum and why
exactly this play with like what is
crazy people
yeah the Marquis de Sade that all these
quote-unquote crazy people are acting in
that's what I was thinking I think
probably most of the people asylum we're
not crazy because back in the day they
would just throw anybody assylum for
anything so I imagine like maybe some of
them has a mental problem
makes a lot more just odd don't you bet
a lot more just purchased or just had
like inconvenient political views or
basically they talked about as an
arthouse film that's yes that's
essentially what this was yeah so for a
while he kind of had like free-range
like he was even like humping like the
other people that like worked there and
like I there's no like no one stopped at
me and I mean so he was just kind of
like living the high life now in 1809
like apparently like a new you know
police regime came in and they were like
oh no no we can't have that so they
stopped all that they said no more
theater productions no more paper and
pens for him it's like this is supposed
to be punishment so they took all his
[ __ ] away
now also during this time he started
another relations like it wasn't enough
that he had like the mistress living in
the room next door in the insane asylum
but he also started banging a
fourteen-year-old girl named Madeline
Leclerc who was the daughter of someone
that worked at the insane asylum he had
some pull you must have some pull too
had to get all of this [ __ ] I mean yes
he spent a lot of his years in prison or
an insane asylum but look at all the
[ __ ] he got away with how old was he at
this time good time on in 30s no this is
like this is when he's old he said oh
he's like 69 or 70 at this point he's 70
he's banging a fourteen-year-old yes
from the insane asylum
it's that girl that man that's most I
think he was 70 yeah he's got he's kind
of way with himself huh and you have
that as you mentioned like near the
beginning of the show by the time that
he was this age and he was in the insane
asylum he was ugly by this time yeah he
was real fat yeah he was real fat also
that's some weird [ __ ]
nothing like geoffrey rush in quills he
wasn't sexy at all the the woman he was
banging didn't look anything like Kate
Winslet it wasn't like that he must have
had a way with words I can't talk his
way into some [ __ ] must been I can't
think of anything that a [ __ ]
could say
I seriously yeah but you know what I
mean if you're fourteen okay I can't
comprehend it okay if I was fourteen and
like some weird 70 year old man as
though he's in an insane asylum Asst I
would leave like sniffing like ass
Benjamin Franklin and he's got a [ __ ]
low I wanna be all about you know a
long-ass criminal history and he's gonna
talk his way up it's been a briefing in
Venice toboggan I can't
so fourteen-year-old trim I mean I guess
there wasn't a lot of like options back
then but still everyone was inky gross
but so I don't believe it I don't
believe it still I just I don't know I
don't know maybe that's not true no it
is it's just I don't I don't know like I
said I don't know how consensual it was
it's not like he had a problem with I
think it must have been consensual she
was 14 though come in he's 70 yeah how
is he gonna force this into reality he
could sooner he was fat he talked her
into some huh maybe he just sat if I'm
an insane asylum he sat on her head with
his [ __ ] volcano his ship I'm just you
know I'm just blue skying I don't really
know he made [ __ ] volcanoes up that's
not a possibility the volcano has stuff
would snap off you would think that a
Snapple yeah right right yeah and
honestly if you were that old because
the woman in the book I'm like I said
it's a fictional novel obviously but the
woman in the book that supposedly had
the [ __ ] volcano I think she was 56 or
60 or she was [ __ ] ever once wife and
is and never once wiped her ass I'm like
your she was like fester and you would
die this is a Mark II come on it's kind
of like that girl that we heard of
dinner Swami locked her up for running
off left her in there forever
remember that and she was in the [ __ ] in
crustacean yeah remember that yeah kind
of what was the name of that [ __ ]
case I don't know yeah you guys know
Thomas she was found laying on her side
and crusted
and like a like a [ __ ] let's ride up
[ __ ]
we call it Grand Canyon on either side
of her like a canyon yeah
and that and what was what else was in
there there was a boy stur shells this
is back in the 1800s and then they
arrested the mom for locking her up
remember that and then the mom died in
prison in jail you know remember that
case not really I was i I just kept
thinking of that one that the girl next
door was based on that kid not involved
there was a case where a young girl was
getting ready to run off with some dude
the mom got pissed off so she took the
barrel and locked her up in a room in a
dark room by herself her whole life most
of her adult life and then the mom grew
the mom ended up to me and what in her
like mid 70s and then the police that
the police got a got a message that
there was that an old lady was keeping
her daughter imprisoned inside the house
and then they went they broke in they
found her and then they locked her mama
yeah
there's pictures of her that was in the
early 1900s actually yeah well I'd have
to look it up but I yeah we might want
to do a show on that that weird [ __ ]
there so he starts banging this
fourteen-year-old girl this last for
four years now he actually ended up
dying in 1814 now as I said the movie
quills kind of showed him getting
tortured to death or anything like they
were trying to make him a martyr which
is a little bit [ __ ] up like I said I
liked that movie but it's really
historically inaccurate he actually
ended up dying very peacefully in his
sleep at the age of 74 now he had said
in his will specifically that he did not
want he wanted okay he did not want his
body opened for any so he didn't an
autopsy or anything like that he's like
I want you to leave my body in the cell
for 48 hours and don't touch it and then
come in and it's like bury it out on my
property and he wanted um I can't
remember the exact quote but he wanted
like acorns and trees and like he wanted
everything to grow over his grave so no
one would know where it was so everyone
would forget him like he
wanted that he didn't want his feet want
to be dug up and [ __ ] desert crated
as well that we'll see how that worked
out but yes so but what ended up
happening was that someone particularly
probably out of spite I would think
actually gave him a Christian burial
with a cross and everything which he
would have hated so and after he died
like I said his son he probably hated
his guts burned most of his manuscripts
and everything like that now like I said
a lot of the [ __ ] that he wrote he did
write a lot of stuff but a lot of it
wasn't published until later and some of
it was like actually lost or destroyed
so but what ended up happening is that
he gets buried and like not that long
afterward you know the you know
phrenologist that thought that all of
your personality traits could be seen by
like the shape of your head ha ha ha so
yeah some so one of those guys was like
I need to get my hands on that [ __ ]
skull so he goes and like raids the
grave and takes his skull
now he makes a cast or he loaned the
skull to another phrenologist and the
other friend Hall is just made off with
it now apparently this phrenologist made
a cast of it and then for a long time
they didn't know where the actual skull
was like it kind of bounced around like
to different museums and stuff I think
they found it at this point I think it's
in the anthropological the Museum of Man
and friend Paris so I think they have
his actual skull now but it's funny that
it kind of that he specifically did not
want his he did not want a Christian
burial because like I said he was very
adamantly an atheist and he just hated
all religion and he did not want anybody
touching his body or autopsy and those
two things happened because yeah people
were just like [ __ ] you man person's
gonna do whatever so now the interesting
oh [ __ ] him yeah kind of well the
interesting thing though was that as I
mentioned earlier because a lot of his
stuff was published anonymously when he
was alive during the 19th century his
[ __ ] wasn't widely available like his
his works weren't widely available now
there were like a kind of an elite like
you're in election
your writers like a lot of Enlightenment
thinkers and stuff like that like I said
like flow Barre like Charles Baudelaire
like you know people like that if you
were kind of like in the know or in that
scene the the manuscripts kind of got
passed around and so I feel like in that
way he sort of became a figure of
admiration sort of because of his he
advocated like a kind of sexual Liberty
which a lot of those type of writers
were doing at the time um you know I I
don't know if a lot of them actually
advocated or even knew like all the [ __ ]
that he got up to when he was alive but
in his writings they found they're like
yeah we need to push the boundaries we
need to like get rid of all these like
moralistic structures and stuff like
that which you know that's fine now his
stuff wasn't really widely published
until I think is the first widely
available you know copy of one of his
works was not until 1904 at which point
he kind of got like you know an
intellectual resurgence I guess because
a lot of people got interested in his
work and some people that were really
interested in work were the surrealist
like Salvador Dali was really intuition
Lewis boon well they made like a couple
things like based on his works and he
kind of became a sort of like cultural
transgressive touchstone I feel like
like it later on you know like hey Suze
Franco made [ __ ] Justine with Klaus
Kinski in it you know Pasolini made Salo
120 days of sodom which was a loose
adaptation of 120 days of sodom except
you know updated to fascist Italy world
war ii italy where he's kind of like
making he's kind of like highlighting
the hypocrisy of these ruling elites
[ __ ] over the working-class is kind of
like what he was doing which i get that
how you could do that message and you
can kind of like you know see that in
his work and everything like that but
you know considering what he did in his
real life i just don't think that can be
justified because the class is [ __ ]
you over doesn't mean it gives you wear
doesn't buckle you're a liar yeah that's
what I mean and it's funny because you
know it's we're really weird the the
book that Sophie sent me the one with
the Ian Brady great the gates of Jannah
yeah
Ian Brady the Moors murder now Ian Brady
was actually a big fan of the Marquis de
Sade's he was a Nietzsche who was
Nietzsche who was influenced by these I
[ __ ] him over well he was very
influenced by the sod though and they
and a lot of their ideas are similar so
Ian Brady was like a big fan and have
like some of his books and things and
honestly like some of des sods works
were banned in the UK for a time because
of that because of their association
with Ian Brady and it's interesting
because when you read that book that Ian
Brady wrote a lot of his ideas sound
very similar to what desaad was saying
where because you know the church is
hypocritical because the government is
hypocritical because they're allowed to
have the death penalty they do this they
[ __ ] people over they use so somehow
like you like it's okay if you do it too
it almost seems like that's what they're
saying yeah MoMA speak up in defense of
Nietzsche though
Nietzsche a [ __ ] was anti solipsism
in other words yeah you can do what you
want to do but you gotta understand that
other people can do it they want to do
you know what I mean which is something
that always which is yeah do what you
want to do but there's [ __ ]
reciprocation involved there's gonna be
[ __ ] blowback we'll see about that
always and I was thinking about this
earlier today that I find it very
interesting that the Marquis de Sade and
a lot of guys that that are like this
it's like they're very you know they're
very set on you know and they kind of
like get a lot of mileage out of oh I
can do whatever I want to do but then if
someone imposes their will on them at
all they don't like it like immediately
because he was like when he was in
prison he was just like whining about
how put-upon he was and I feel like
that's a very common thing with these
types of dudes is that as long as they
in power and they're doing what they
want to do and you can't say anything
about it then it's fine but if somebody
tries to you know use your philosophy
against you I'm going to impose my will
on you now [ __ ] and then they don't
like it this is gonna take me back to
which you know which is hypocritical in
itself because you're only advocating
that philosophy for you and not for
everyone else exactly you got to go back
to [ __ ] writers like [ __ ] you know
Minamoto Musashi and [ __ ] songs ooh
you have no right at all to take the
life of another person unless you
yourself are able to give up your life
without complaint
I'm talking about and I would agree with
that's like a kamikaze type mentality
you have no right to kill another person
until you're ready to die yeah and it's
and you can scale that down too
you don't have your right you have no
right to do anything bad against another
person until you're ready to accept the
consequences that's what I mean what you
[ __ ] did and you got guys like you
got guys like [ __ ] the Marquis who
are a very classist where they're gonna
[ __ ] over some [ __ ] peasant girl big
and then get pissed off when when they
get put in jail or whatever right yeah
that's not how it goes
don't get mad about it don't get mad
about it [ __ ] you reap what you sow
you live by the sword you die by the
sword that's what I mean that's the
Nightwind Minamoto Musashi and [ __ ] I
would be pissed I mean okay now in some
way and EJ was like that too you live by
the sword you die by the sword
yeah you have to [ __ ] get ready for
that in some ways I have to like I will
give the Marquis this much credit at
least yes he was pointing out the
hypocrisy of the church yes he was
pointing out like the hypocrisy of like
government officials who were like
saying one thing and doing another fair
enough and that's true and at least he
was at least the Marquis was honest
about what a [ __ ] he was and the [ __ ]
that he was doing at least he was open
about it I'm not saying that's good like
the [ __ ] that he did but at least it was
mark
annalee better that he was admitting it
and not hot and not pretending that he
was to be something that he wasn't he
basically said yeah I'm the worst witch
okay at least he was honest about it I
will give him that much leeway but he
was doing the same [ __ ] that other
people were doing just the fact that he
wasn't lying about it doesn't make it it
makes it like a millimeter better but
that's about it
yeah and I just I feel like I don't know
I just I just feel like there's this
whole I'm not so like I said I'm not
saying that you know we should burn his
[ __ ] novel journey so their novels
it's like you can write whatever you
want a novel you can put whatever you
want in a movie as long as you know
people who want to read it can read it
if you don't want to read it don't read
it but the fact that he did what he did
and he felt like he had almost like the
right to do that because these people
were not people to him or they didn't
have the same rights as he had or
something like that and it just it seems
like his whole worldview and I felt that
when I was reading in Brady's book too
it's like it it feels like he thinks
that he's a lot smarter than he is but
when you're reading his [ __ ] it's like
blaringly hypocritical yeah even though
he's condemning hypocrisy and other
people but it's hypocritical what
they're saying is that's the problem
with these kind of guys yes and that's
it that's why it makes me so angry
yeah it's that it's almost kind of like
they see like this far but they can't
see they're not like self-aware enough
to see yeah what I see like with the
moment is a good example of solipsism in
me yes okay
don't ban the Marquee you just
understand the marquee for what he is he
the marquee was a [ __ ] sex offender
he was a shitbird yeah if that dude got
ahold of my daughter I don't have a
daughter but if he got ahold of my
daughter or my son this is [ __ ] I would
have killed that [ __ ]
and rightfully so yes I said you know
any anyone would have done the same and
he would have complained that's what I
mean yes so you do at least don't
complain I own that [ __ ] yeah yeah you
just wanna you know
taking for what it is an understanding
for what it is the dude was a dirtbag
yeah yeah he wrote some [ __ ] wild ass
porn he did some [ __ ] wild ass [ __ ]
but he was a shitbird
yeah and he spent a lot of time in the
[ __ ] prisons in bestia where he
belonged if he was around today you
would never have known that dude he
would have just been locked up yeah and
you'd have been like [ __ ] yeah what a
creep yeah yeah there's lots of guys
like that there's serial killers a
serial rapist that's what and that's it
that's a [ __ ] rapist pretty much who
he aligns with yes he was a good writer
yes he was probably an important writer
in the context of his time in the
context of the ideas that were coming
about in the time but you know as a
person and that's a great but you know
what I found was really interesting I
found this [ __ ] article in The
Guardian or something like that from
like 2015 and they were talking to a guy
named I think is I guess you pronounce
it Hugh Hugh desaad who is his direct
descendent now the weird thing about
this is that as I said because his stuff
was published and honestly or you know
it was banned in a lot of places and
stuff like that so it didn't really get
a wide release into the 1900s so the
weird thing was that he was saying that
their family for a long time because the
marquis de sade
not only had burned a lot of his [ __ ]
but it kind of like crossed him out of
the genealogies and stuff like that
because he wanted him like an athame he
wasn't him like erased from history so
for a long time the family either didn't
know he existed or pretended he didn't
exist so up until the 1940s the desaad
family who were still living in the same
area and [ __ ] like that didn't realize
that they were direct descendants of the
Marquis de Sade's he wasn't like super
famous right because his [ __ ] didn't
really get published until the 1900s so
the weird thing was this historian who
was fascinated by the Marquis de Sade
approaches you know the family in the
1940s said hey this is your ancestor and
they were kind of like huh we didn't
know about that guy because like I said
they had kind of like tried to like
erase him and they said well why don't
you like check out some [ __ ] so they go
to Lacoste which was still there or
there
ancestral home or whatever and they
found a bunch of his like letters and
manuscripts that that no one had ever
found before so they found like letters
so like his kids and his wife and [ __ ]
like that they found like all this stuff
and so like they ended up publishing it
the weird thing about it is that it you
know in the US and even if you see like
[ __ ] cheesy ass like horror movies
from the eighties like wax work and
stuff like that like wax work has the
Marquis de Sade in it but he's like a
villain like he's a bit like one of the
twelve worst people in the world or
something like that whatever the purpose
of that movie was but in France he's not
a national hero or anything like that
but he is seen as like literate like
important from a literary standpoint as
they would then phrase as yet you know
just his ideas were important I think
they realized he was he kind of sucked
but it's like his ideas were important
so they deuce in ancient degenerate yes
so he I mean they'll give him like he
had a big the musee de the musee d'orsay
had like a big like [ __ ] exhibition
of like [ __ ] that was like influenced by
him cuz they're talking about like
transgressive like art and film and
stuff like that like in light of him and
how influential he was like over a lot
of that stuff which he was if you think
about it so they have like a big
exhibition on that and then they I was
reading this interview with his direct
descendant like Hugh desaad who
apparently he decided because the
Marquis reputation has been I don't want
to say whitewashed but it's not as bad
as it was in at least in France so he
said well I'm gonna make some money out
of this [ __ ] so he basically started a
kind of a luxury goods company called
the Maison des Saud I mean it's his
family and so he sells like [ __ ] that's
you know famous from the Provence area
like wines and you know different kinds
of meat like quail and stuff like that
and it's like really expensive [ __ ] and
he sells that he even has like a wide
like a line of wines like desaad that
has like a naked lady on the front and
apparently like it's like this big thing
and I heard I don't know if this ever
came to pass or not but he was talking
about in this 2015 article that he was
talking to Victoria's Secret about
starting a line of lingerie oh so a base
and by and by I don't know if that I'm
all happen or not because you know what
I mean
local dead malls yes well that's what I
was thinking because I don't know if
Victoria Secret is doing all that well
like nowadays no five years later but in
2015 they were talking about doing it
then so I don't know but another thing
that he does sell is remember how I said
like his skull got like taken by the
phrenologist and everything and
apparently they did find it they had a
cast of and everything so now this dude
like sells bronze replicas for the
actual skull and they're like five
thousand euros or some [ __ ] I was like
well you know whatever it's his family
member it's like if people wanna it's
funny because I heard that the Marquis
decide
like the u.s. refused to import it
because porn yeah I I don't think that
desaad would have been a very big deal
back in his day he's sort of been
considered to be a degenerate [ __ ]
well as I said I think a lot of
aristocrats were doing the same [ __ ]
that he did just the fact that he made
such a big production out of it well got
him in trouble I'm not sure you're I
don't think your average corrupt French
nobleman did the amount of debauchery
that he did I really did think he maxed
it out if he did that on purpose he
trying to do I think he tried it doc
everybody said that yeah but he probably
was just like a [ __ ] extremely
[ __ ] extremely predatory by sexual
sadist that would probably just explain
everything and like you said you'd
literally could not trust anyone around
no human animal in anime age I would say
he you know if if everything is true
what they say about him he was we call
it a sex addict yeah sex a device I feel
like even if you left him in your house
nobody in there I wouldn't touch
anything in the house because he
probably rubbed his taint and his balls
all over every single runner now what
would impress me
i'ma tell you like you were gone I'm
gonna tell you what would really impress
me about decide what that is if that he
was actually a dude that really didn't
get any and this was all a fantasy and
he's just writing about it and then he
got everyone to believe it he got
everyone to believe that he was that all
this which you know there's a chance
where that might be partially although
so many people reported yes to me okay
so worried about is telling you earthly
supports I mean so many women yeah he
was essential to his house okay today he
would just consider him to be a [ __ ]
he would just be a serial rapist yeah
and in a way like kudos to the sips to
France in the 1700s at least they put
this [ __ ] yeah like we don't
know his life we don't know what we
didn't even care like what that is but
this is this is bad
France and back in those 17 years be
like we don't really know what a serial
rapist is but we got a lock your ass up
yes I'm not good yeah so they at least
knew enough to do that they do enough to
that yeah so you know alright so we've
probably gone on long enough about the
Marquis de Sade Tom's getting very very
drunk I don't [ __ ] loaded I probably
am having a good time though well that's
good
so we'll probably do I can remain
standing so yeah so we're gonna wrap
this up for this week hope you guys
enjoyed episode 185 remember if you like
the show like share subscribe on all
your social social media check out our
new Instagram we've had that up for a
few weeks so we've had like a bunch of
people follow us so go over there and
check us out if you haven't already if
you'd like to financially support the
show of course you can go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
com and there's a button in the sidebar
that goes right to a PayPal account if
you'd like to but one-time donation
anything would be much appreciated and
we will see you next time bye
so he gets lured back in understand this
you're gonna get in big trouble stop
tearing up the paper I'm tearing up
paper stop tearing out the paper so
crazy yeah she wants a tangent yeah
you're tearing up paper stop it
it's but it's a pathological behavior of
paper
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]